HandsNTx
Poland
Dies ist dieizzy Maut, leude.
Ich mach das wieder raus demnächst.
Opa, warum eigentlich nicht?
Das ist schon grenzwertig irgendwie.
Nein, nein, dann lass ich's halt drin.
Null.
HD.
XD.
5K.
Nee, 4K.
So.
Ich warte jetzt bloß noch bis Twitch kapiert hat, dass der Stream online ist.
Alright Leute, ich bin irgendwie kaputt, aber ich hab mir gedacht, ich mach heute Abend nochmal Stream an.
vor wie ja ich muss ein paar sachen einkaufen da gucken wir noch ein paar videos wir schwätzen
ein bisschen vielleicht basteln wir auch ich weiß es nicht mal gucken irgendwann bis 22 uhr
oder so weil ihr wisst ja chat was ist um 22 uhr ihr wisst 22 uhr ist betge time genau so sieht
aus betge betge betge halt white people happy geht so 20k viewer lol ja genau 20
millionen sind in wirklichkeit lügt doch nicht
moin samuel neues video stimmt so ein kommando wäre gar nicht schlecht wer es noch nicht gesehen
hat ich habe ein neues video und dieses video hat youtube erst überhaupt nicht gecheckt es hat eine
viertel stunde gebraucht bis überhaupt nennenswert jetzt außer über twitter und discord wo ich
gepostet habe es hat eine viertel stunde gebraucht bis youtube überhaupt mitgekriegt dass das video
richtig und ist dafür jetzt kleint es ganz gut von den städten von den statistik her jetzt bei
euch aus chat windows 11 schon am start oder kein bock also ich handhab es ja so ich habe
es ja schon im video gesagt ich werde warten entweder bis windows 10 end of life ist oder
irgendwas gibt dass ich unbedingt haben will oder aber ich kaufe mir neuen rechner also sollte
ich mir wirklich mal einen rechner kaufen was ja aktuell schwierig ist weil du kriegst ja nichts
und wenn du was kriegst ist es auch schon wieder alt also wenn wenn es beispielsweise jetzt mal
die nächste video generation gibt also dann überlege ich mir tatsächlich mal je nachdem
wie teuer das wird und dann werde ich wahrscheinlich windows 11 drauf machen denke ich mal sollte
windows 10 nicht das letzte sein ja und nein also offiziell sagt ja microsoft haben sie das nie
gesagt aber das wurde schon aber so so propagiert ja also da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten
aber ganz ehrlich jeder von uns wusste dass windows 10 nicht das letzte windows sein wird
jetzt noch ganz klar in microsoft 2016 oder so wann kam das raus 2015 das gesagt hat dann
ist uns doch klar dass das nicht für immer ist wo punkt im stream titel nummer eins informatiker
punkt tv dann gehen da noch leute auf die webseite und zweifelsfall ist es eine russische
scam seite oder so was hältst du von github actions ich finde ich gut haben wir auch schon
öfters im stream benutzt für irgendwelche projekte github actions guck mal zum beispiel
zum beispiel github wo blurz moment moment keck wss service wo ist keck wss service keck wss
service hat glaube ich github actions dabei für hetzer cloud deployment ich meine das
ist ein shell script was man ehrlich gesagt auch lokal ausführen könnte und nicht unbedingt
über github actions laufen lassen müsste aber es funktioniert ja und davor baut die
dotnet anwendung und publish die dotnet anwendung nee ich weiß es ist gleiche publish oder bilden
und dann schiebts das auf den server drauf aber github actions ist nice ich finde das
finde das gut ich finde was ich an github actions auch gut finde ist dass das free kontingent
relativ großzügig ist zumindest bin ich noch nie irgendwie ans limit auch nur ansatzweise
gestoßen windows 10 ist das letzte offline windows naja wenn die so weitermachen ich
habe es ja heute gelesen wieder account zwang hier pc welt ist wieder strebt mir kommen
wir gehen computer based schon geht schon besser pc welt leute ich hatte mal pc welt
aber vor vor ganz ganz langer zeit sage euch pc welt ich habe aber auch mal regelmäßig
eine zeit lang am kiosk damals auch computer bild gekauft lacht mich nicht aus ja aber
das ist schon lange her und die pc welt ist die etwas bessere computer bild aber also
eigentlich sind beide nicht so gut und irgendwann habe ich dann einfach die ct abonniert und
nie wieder was anderes geholt und ich habe seit ich habe das ct aber immer noch laufen
mich habe hier eine riesen stapel cts ich habe bestimmt die letzten vier jahre kaum
noch cts gelesen ne vier vier jahre ist übertrieben er untertrieben die letzten die letzten sieben
jahre oder so bestimmt schon keine ct mehr regelmäßig gelesen seit ich mehrere tablets
smartphones und gedöns habe ich habe die ct zum größten teil nur gelesen wenn es
ein bisschen länger gedauert hat und seitdem ich da jetzt immer mal smartphone und tablet
mitnehmen ist teilweise schon dauerhaft auf dem klo brauche ich keine ct mehr ist auch
wenig dabei ist auch wenig dabei was mich interessiert irgendwie letzten jahre glaube
ich glaube das liegt liegt schlicht und ergreifend daran die ct ist die beste das beste computer
magazin was es gibt insofern dass es jeder interessierte lesen kann und versteht ja aber
wahrscheinlich ich könnte mir vorstellen ich bin vielleicht einfach aus den aus der
ct rausgewachsen mittlerweile also da ist so wenig drin noch wo ich sagen würde das ist
ein interessantes thema habe ich nie was von gehört das interessiert mich wie es geht
koa ct aber trotzdem irgendwie das aber behalte ich immer noch also wenn schon müsste ich
das in x abo machen aber da ich gucke öfters mal so drüber was also die titel themen sind
schockt mich jetzt auch nicht so nee nicht wirklich ct das ist quasi die das ist das
magazin von heise was ist lustig ist dass sie noch nicht mal die ct überhaupt irgendwie
auf heise stehen haben naja ehrlich gesagt nicht in der heutigen zeit eigentlich du
hast das internet und ich habe es immer nur auf dem klo gelesen und da habe ich jetzt
auch tablet und internet und geht uns was ist das hier was ich auch ab an direkt storage
gut also immer ach ja was ist denn jetzt mit dem minders elf account 28 so hier guck da
windows elf 22 h 2 also das ist ja quasi die ubuntu versionierung die sie jetzt umbenannt
haben also zweites halbjahr also das ist quasi windows elf 22 punkt zehn wenn man das mal
in ubuntu maßstäben nimmt und da haben sie jetzt geplant endgültig den sack zuzumachen
was offline accounts angeht und ehrlich leute man sieht sie letzten jahre über schon sie
haben immer wieder anläufe genommen sie haben immer wieder gesagt hey wir machen es jetzt
wir machen es jetzt noch ekliger offline accounts zu machen und jetzt brauchst du drei unter
menüs und dann brauchst du beispielsweise mit der home version gar nicht mehr richtig
dann musstest du das netzwerk kabel ausstecken es wurde immer ekliger immer mehr abfack
und jetzt sagen sie beim vorbei account zwang das finde ich persönlich natürlich abgrundtief
beschissen weil ich will kein microsoft account brauchen um mich an meinem lokalen rechner
anzumelden ich habe ein microsoft account ich bin sogar angemeldet mit dem microsoft
account aber ich will das nicht für mein lauren brauchen das geht mir mega auf den
sack zumal ich auch hier im stream guck mal im stream haben wir doch bestimmt schon 20
30 windows installation mal schnell auf der vm gemacht und das geht da nicht mehr das
ist doch müll ist doch richtig beschissen soll ich mir das immer in fake account anlegen
bevor wir irgendwie windows uns was angucken ich gehe auch davon aus dass es möglichkeiten
gibt das zu umgehen also was auf jeden fall funktionieren wird ist wenn du das ding irgendwie
mit dem active directory verbindet das muss sein also aus aus aus unternehmenssicht glaube
nicht dass ich das da durchsetzen lässt allerdings macht sie active directory verbinden nicht
während der installation also ich keine ahnung ich weiß es nicht vielleicht braucht man
dafür die enterprise version dass es dann nicht geht sind fake accounts eigentlich legal
naja ja sind sie sie sind legal sie verstoßen vielleicht gegen die microsoft nutzung nutzungsbedingungen
aber das heißt also das ist ja was anderes also wenn du gegen die microsoft nutzungsbedingungen
verstößt heißt es ja nicht dass du gegen deutsches geltendes rechts verstößt das
heißt microsoft kann im zweifelsstand account band aber das war es dann auch ja es ist halt
echt bescheuert leute wisst ihr was mich mal interessieren will jetzt ganz was anderes
falls ihn mal einer im discord sieht mich würde echt interessieren wie es dem sebaro geht wie
geht es unserem cute mod nummer eins ehe ich nichts mehr gesehen das bestimmt mit seinem
lehramts grill beschäftigt und mit seinem studium und sonst was mich echt mal interessieren was
der so treibt beziehungsweise da alles ob da alles läuft fips moin ja so zumindest das finde
ich natürlich beschissen und ich frage mich was der nächste trick sein wird viertelstunde
netzwerkstecker raus oder es gibt bestimmt mittel und wege die sachen zu umgehen aber
es wird immer mehr abfangen echter sebaro hat was geschrieben vor ein paar tagen habe ich nicht
gesehen wisst ihr was wisst ihr was sein wird dass man demnächst ein linux booted mit dem
anderen windows installiert in einer minimal version wurde es schon gepatcht ist mit dem
account zwang irgendwie sowas wachs interessierst du dich eigentlich für irgendeine art sport auch
rennsport oder ich ich habe früher tatsächlich relativ viel ratsport geguckt ich war nie der
große fahrradfahrer aber das ist auch schon lange her aktuell interessiere ich mich hauptsächlich
tatsächlich für größere e-sport events aller art also ich gucke ich gucke von cs bis starcraft
einzige was ich nicht mag ist tatsächlich ist dota und lol also mobas ist nicht so meins aber
ansonsten wie gesagt von cs bis bis starcraft teilweise guck ich gucke ich sogar ab und zu
mal art store oder sowas und bei art store ist halt wirklich e-sport lulvee na guckst du pg ja ab
und zu mal wenn das das ist was ich denke ist das das in den niederlanden oder keine ahnung
du bringst bringst kann sein ich durch dann erbring übrigens ich muss euch was erzählen
e-sport technisch letztens war ich eis essen und der verkäufer ich hatte eine asus mütze auf
ich hatte ich hatte eine ich hatte eine asus mütze auf die habe ich irgendwo mal bei der
gamescom abgegriffen keine ahnung ist ewig her asus asus asus mütze auf und auf einmal
fehlt fängt er mir an zu erzählen ja was ich denn spielen würde und wie sieht es mit counter
strike aus und da wusste erst mal gar nicht was ich dazu sagen sollte so aus dem stegreif
habe ich halt irgendwas unverfängliches gesagt ja ja also ich gucke ich weiß kein was erzählen
irgendwie ja so das letzte battlefield war ja enttäuschend aber gibt er immer noch gute
irgendwie was unverfängliches und der typ der hat mir dann weiter erzählen auf einmal das fand
ich wirklich extrem nice er meinte er hat früher counter strike gespielt und zwar richtig semi pro
und zwar bis zur fuck jetzt habe ich vergessen welches land das war slovenien serbien serbien
bis bis in in die serbische serbische cs nationalmannschaft gut das ist jetzt nichts
tolles denke ich mal was die internationale reichweite angeht weil ganz ehrlich die ganzen
cs turniere sind ja nicht irgendwelche landesmeisterschaft oder sonst was aber
trotzdem fand ich cool mein eisverkäufer erzählt mehr hat früher in der serbischen
nationalmannschaft gespielt was er jetzt spielt keine ahnung immer noch zerst stimmt immer noch
zuerst hat er gesagt das fand ich wirklich cool aha ok nächste mal wenn ich eis essen geht
ziehe ich mein nipp mein nipp kappa auf du guckst auf den klo in wubbler auf youtube kenne ich nicht
und was wenn man sich nicht einloggt hast wahrscheinlich pech
hast du schon was von twister os ja habe ich das sagt mir was da habe ich letztens in video
zugesehen war das nicht das was irgendwie so windows windows für ein raspberry pi oder so was
ne ist gar nicht so dann habe ich mich vertan dann habe ich mich vertan deswegen xfc und warum
sollte man das dann verwenden wenn das einfach nur ein weiterer xfc reskin ist
ne ich meine ich reaktor als reaktor reaktor es ist unbrauchbar habe ich schon paar mal ausprobiert
warum ok warum sollte man das verwenden
true desktop computing experience hat er hat ein windows design hast box 86 und
weint drauf gut das kann ich aber überall anders auch nach installieren ich mein es
ist halt nix fc es sieht auch aus wie nix fc spätestens wenn du an wenn du nach installierst
wo sie keine default skin für haben bricht das halt eben wieder komplett zusammen ist
halt der fluch und segen zugleich von oja das wichtig minecraft läuft der fluch und
segen zugleich von linux offen desktop
ja katt alles klar pokemon ural ist es nicht das was was was nintendo down gestricked hat
war doch in den rpg maker pokemon wo viele fans gesagt haben das wäre näher an pokemon
dran als alles was nintendo die letzten jahre so released hat
ja ist richtig bescheuert wahrscheinlich braucht es jetzt die enterprise version dafür dass
es keine account zwang mehr gibt richtig hängen geblieben
ihr nutzt auf der arbeit täglich teams ja das stimmt die ladezeit ein paar teams sind
wirklich eklig und ist mittlerweile extrem ressourcen fressen aber ich muss sagen ich
finde teams tatsächlich ganz ok die bauen tatsächlich also auch wenn ich jetzt das
komische zeichnen über microsoft sage aber die bauen tatsächlich ab und zu richtig
gute sachen ein zum beispiel das automatische hintergrund entfernen dieses ai basierte hintergrund
löschen wurde dann beispielsweise dich auf wegen den halo ding setzen kannst oder so
also aus dem spiel was ich ganz praktisch finde weil bei mir ist es im hintergrund gerade
nicht so aufgeräumt und ich mache jetzt immer background löschen und blöde in hintergrund
oder mach irgendwas in hintergrund als bild und das finde ich ist ein gutes feature gibt
es ja bestimmt aber du musst halt erst einmal starten mit cmd also das musst du irgendwie
während dem installieren hinkriegen wenigstens cortana weg ist die wirklich weg da ist immer
noch ich mache die jetzt nicht auf cortana war echt die sinnloseste erfindung aller
zeiten dass ich mein apple und hat mit siri quasi so so angefangen damals ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob alexa oder siri zuerst war wisst ihr das wisst ihr ich glaube siri war
mit zuerst und danach kam irgendwann alexa und dann war die sache eigentlich eigentlich
schon besiegelt ja weil mehr was eigentlich gar nicht gebraucht und dann kam natürlich
noch google ist klar die dürfen nicht fehlen war sowas so und oder kam google zuerst ja
doch ich glaube sogar google kam zuerst zumindest irgendwann kam dann microsoft auch und hat
sich gedacht aber wir machen jetzt auch mal was cortana war ja eine coole idee also dass
es cortana ist aber er hat keine was ist eigentlich aus aus samsung sam ne wie ist denn die nicht
samsung sam welche hersteller war das nein nein nein nein nein nein war das samsung
sam ja ja samsung sam ja jetzt weiß ich wieder was ist denn daraus eigentlich geworden gibt
es das ding jetzt mittlerweile das ist das dass das ist das wo samsung einfach nur bilder
veröffentlicht hat von ihrem neuen assistant und danach ist sowohl die cosplay welt als
auch wie wir umschreiben wir das jetzt rule 34 etwas amok gelaufen bisher gab es innerlich
auch nicht schon mal sim racing gesehen ja finde ich jetzt nicht so spannend ich finde
auch real life motorsport nicht so spannend aber ein kollege bei mir auf der arbeite
ist richtig in so simulations zeug der spielt sowohl dcs als auch auf wie heißt dieses dieses
renn simulations ding was voll heißt es sich heißt es irgendwie ein racing das könnte
ein racing sein ja es könnte ein racing sein oder ein multiplayer fährt und und ja ja ich
glaube ein racing ist das der geht darauf ab auf so simulations graben also ganz im ernst
ich glaube wenn das so weitergeht mit der verbreitung von windows elf dann wird uns
wahrscheinlich ein support eine support verlängerung für windows zehn ins haus stehen und am minus
zwölf was sollen sie dann sonst machen sarex moin mir war das auch unangenehm muss ich
sagen aber der war halt äußerst kommunikativ ja die nvidia schuhe ja ich kann die nvidia
schuhe anziehen aber die sind für au na ja doch aktuell gehen die eigentlich ist ja
warm generals lane danke für den sub was steht heute an nix großartiges wir kaufen
noch ein paar sachen ein guck noch ein paar videos schwätzt ein bisschen nix ich habe
einfach gesagt ich mache noch mal stream an was für ein ding schiff plus f10 dann oobe bypass
bypass nr o abschicken neustart eine ganze off-line kunde 5 header time ob die abkürzung
kenne ich das ist microsoft logik wisst ihr wofür ob steht das ist die out of box experience
microsoft hat für jeden müll irgendwelche wörter also du bypass die out of box experience
was nr o steht habe ich keine ahnung bypass nao nao windows nero nein er nicht nero gibt
es doch irgendwelche leute die überhaupt brenner in ihren rechnern drinne haben das ist auch
so ein ding gibt es gibt es sowas überhaupt noch dvd brenner doch so 17 euro kostet so
was kirk weight man in der hochzeit von diesen dingen dann hatte ich drei stücke im rechner
gibt es cd brenner noch tatsächlich gibt es gibt es hd dvd brenner gibt es blu blu
ray brenner tatsächlich ich weiß nicht dass man das wirklich brauchen würde gibt es eigentlich
schon in dem nachfolger für blu ray weil ich habe ja damals schon gesagt war blu ray dass
es wahrscheinlich die letzte das letzte optische medium sein wird weil es keinen wirklichen
bedarf mehr gibt für optische medien gibt es geht gibt es keine nachfolge oder interessant
also wie gesagt zur hochzeit der ganze der ganze sache nicht drei drei drei brenner
im rechner das hätte ich mir zur damaligen zeit nicht denken können dass ich nicht nur
den rechner komplett ohne brenner habe sondern ein rechner komplett ohne optisches laufwerk
ich glaube ich habe die letzten zehn jahre kein rechner mit optischen laufwerk gehabt
ich eigentlich sieht man wie schnell sich das tatsächlich gedreht hat dann ich habe
teams auch immer im browser laufen brauchst du nicht du kannst mittlerweile also easy easy
brauchst du nicht brauchst du nicht wenn du kannst mittlerweile abwesenheit abwesenheitszeiten
setzen und du kannst dich einfach in ein single room meeting stecken selbst ohne anderen den
link mitzuteilen wenn du willst dass du auf beschäftigt stehst das mache ich auch manchmal
wenn ich meine ruhe haben will wenn mir die leute permanent auf dem keks gehen in teams
da mache ich einfach mit now es gibt um hier teams mit now gibt es immer nicht news da
gibt es immer so ein bild da mit now einfach den knopf drücken mit now und dann erstellt
teams einen leeren meeting raum wo nur du drinne bist und sagt hier kopiere den einladungslink
oder schicke einladung oder lade leute ein dann ladet ihr einfach keinen ein und wenn
ihr eure ruhe haben wollt ist das das beste weil wenn du wenn du dich auf do not disturb
stellst dann gibt es leute die spam nicht trotzdem weiter voll ich meine du kriegst
vielleicht nicht mit aber die spam nicht trotzdem weiter voll aber hier kannst du es komplett
ignorieren weil die leute erwarten nicht dass du antwortet wenn du wenn du grad mietest
habe ich noch nie gemacht warum geht warum kann man keinen richtigen fullscreen machen
was ich immer bei teams witzig finde wenn irgendwelche leute so was weiß ich 64k monitor
haben oder so daheim der gefühl über die ganze wand geht mit 80 millionen mal 80 millionen
auflösung und dann ihren desktop scheren und der desktop ungefähr so groß ist das
finde ich immer geil die leute scheren ihren desktop mit ihrem ultra bildschirm denken
aber nicht dran dass die anderen leute das vielleicht nicht haben oder hast du dann hast
dann so ein desktop geschert denkst du so hä was was was will der man kann zwar ranzoomen
aber das wird dann bloß noch pixellig mit der zeit
ne ich glaube nicht dass cortana noch weiter cortana eingestellt cortana app für ios
ich meine irgendjemand muss auch edge für android und ios entwickeln
die
Aber selbst das mache ich nie. Also beides. Ich fahre so gut wie in die Auto und dann auch nicht mit dem Voice Assistant.
Das ist der einzige wirklich sinnige Anwendungszweck, den ich so sehe.
Ansonsten überall anders. Ihr kennt doch, wir gucken doch öfters mal die Videos von diesem Typ, der irgendwie 580 verschiedene Smartphone Apps verwendet.
Der hat auch an jeder Ecke irgendwie den Amazon Echo, Sprachassistent und sonst was.
Ich verstehe es nicht, aber jedem so seine Vorlieben.
Also wenn der das mag mit Voice Assistants.
Pog.
Was hat eigentlich weniger User, Windows 11 oder Battlefield 2042?
Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen, Windows 11 hat immerhin 8,89% Anteil.
Das bedeutet, das sind Tausende, Zehntausende, Hunderttausende, keine Ahnung. Versus Battlefield.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind. Sekunde.
Unter 2000. Good Job, Alter. Good Job, Battlefield. Sehr gut. Ich glaube, das ist all time low jetzt, oder?
Gehen die wirklich mittlerweile?
Das haben die doch immer weiter verzögert, diesen Android Emulator. Ist das mittlerweile raus?
Ich finde, das stimmt gar nicht. Ich finde, das ist. Das stimmt gar nicht, weil.
Okay, okay. Windows Versions History, also.
Alter.
Ist da nicht einfach mal normales? Okay, hier, hier, so. Also ich fange jetzt nicht mit den Ollen Kamellen an, ja, so NT und so. Lassen wir, lassen wir weg. Aber
Windows 311 war okay. 95 war okay. 98 war auch okay.
Und jetzt werde ich was sagen, was wahrscheinlich viele Leute mir nicht zustimmen, wenn ME war auch okay.
Das einzige Problem, was ME hatte, ist, dass es mit Windows 2000 und später XP quasi konkurriert ist.
Und dass die einfach von ihrer Linie und der Stabilität her einfach
meilenweit die besseren Systeme waren. Aber in dieser Linie hier 95, 98 ME.
Also ganz im Ernst, ME war weder schlechter noch wirklich viel besser als 98. Es hat den gleichen Nachteil gehabt wie Windows 98.
Die meisten Leute, die heute, das ist aber so die gleichen Nachteile und wenigen Vorteile von Windows 98 im Vergleich zu denen da unten.
Also die ganzen Leute, die heute erzählen, ME war so ein krasser Reihenfall, die waren doch überhaupt nicht dabei.
Die hatten noch damals nicht einen Rechner mit Windows ME drauf. Ich hatte einen Rechner mit Windows ME damals drauf und ich fand den genauso beschissen
wie meinen Rechner mit Windows 95 und Windows 98 drauf. Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass ich es damals nicht besser wusste.
NT hat niemand verwendet daheim, gab keine gescheiten Treiber und nichts für Windows NT.
Also Windows NT konntest du im privaten Bereich nicht verwenden, bis zu 2000 hin.
Und danach hatte man mit einer kurzen Übergangsphase 2000 und dann eben jahrelang XP.
So, also das war okay, das war okay, das war okay, das war okay, das war okay, das war okay.
Äh, Vista und das ist jetzt auch was, Vista war im Vergleich zu XP, ähm, ein ziemlicher, also die haben an Vista relativ viel am Unterbau gemacht.
Also Vista ist beschissen angekommen, weil die Leute auch nicht genau erkannt haben, was da eigentlich ein Vorteil von Vista sein sollte.
Aber in Vista wurden viele Grundsteine gelegt. Ja, beispielsweise wie Windows heute noch.
Ähm, Fenster zeichnet und äh, äh, äh, Fenstertransparenz und das ganze, das kam alles mit Vista.
Aber es wollte kein Mensch benutzen, das ist schon, ist schon wahr. Aber man kann nicht wirklich sagen, dass Vista mega beschissen war.
Es, es, es hat keiner so wirklich den, den Grund gesehen zum Upgraden. Ich auch nicht.
Aber an sich war das quasi ein etwas weiterentwickeltes XP, so schlecht war das jetzt auch nicht.
Dann kam 7, das war wieder richtig, richtig gut, also jeder hat Windows 7 verwendet.
8, ok, Windows 8 ist wirklich die Windows-Version, die ich mit Abstand am schlechtesten finde, weil Windows 8 hat so komplett mich ver-, mich gar nicht, also mich so abgeschreckt,
dass sie angefangen haben mit irgendwie, ähm, äh, Fullscreen-Kacheln und so Müll.
Das fand ich so pains-champ, hab ich nie auch nur im Traum dran gedacht abzukraden.
Aber Windows 8 war das schlechteste, ja, seh ich genauso. 8.1 hab ich nie ausprobiert, keine Ahnung, aber ganz ehrlich, das ist für mich, das zählt für mich dabei.
8.1 wurde doch bloß rausgehauen, weil sie festgestellt haben, dass 8 so katastrophal angekommen ist.
So, danach kam 10, vollkommen in Ordnung, und jetzt 11, tja, es ist kein Windows 8, ja, so weit würde ich nicht gehen.
Es ist aber auch eigentlich kein notwendiges Upgrade gewesen, das ist einzig und allein aus, wir brauchen mal wieder Geldgründen entstanden,
also das könnte ohne Probleme ein Windows 10 Update sein, dieses ganze neue UI-Zeug, was sie da drüber gestürmt haben.
Ich hätt's schöner gefunden, man hätte nicht so Dinge neu entwickelt, die man nicht neu entwickeln musste, wie das Rechtsklick-Menü oder das Start-Menü oder sonst was,
sondern hätte sich mal drauf beschränkt zu sagen, wir machen das Settings-Menü mal einheitlich, wir schmeißen die Dialoge aus Windows 3.11 raus, wir schmeißen die Dialoge aus Windows 5.9 raus.
Ich mein, guckt euch mal diesen Dialog an, ja, warte mal, ich zeig euch mal was, die meisten Leute haben das wahrscheinlich noch nie gemacht.
Ich zeig euch mal was, so, wenn ihr jetzt hier für ein Custom-Icon haben wollt, ach du Scheiße, wo geht denn das?
Leute, nee, Change Icon.
Guckt mal, dieses Menü, das hat sich seit Windows XP oder Windows 95, das hat sich nach Windows, also sowohl diese hässlichen Oldschool-Symbole,
als auch dieses Menü, das hat sich seit Windows 95 nicht geändert.
Guck mal, guck das mal an, was da noch dabei ist.
Ich mein, the fuck?
Oh, ich hab meinen Desktop gescrollt, das war eine schlechte Idee.
Das soll ein Stern sein.
Das sind 16 x 16er Bitmap.
Fucks Menü, ja, also, hätte man das mal ordentlich gemacht und Sachen rausgeschmissen, das hätte ich gut gefunden.
Aber, ich mein, man hat die Taskleiste neu entwickelt als UWP-App für Windows 10?
Nein.
Und jetzt haben wir die Taskleiste aus irgendwelchen Gründen nochmal neu entwickelt, um sie noch schlechter zu machen.
Also, das muss mal einer verstehen.
Naja, gut, aber es ist jetzt kein Windows 2 des Windows 8.
Also, dieses mit Abwechseln, dem würde ich gar nicht so sehr zustimmen.
Das hier unten hat sich ja KaiSao interessiert.
Und ja, es gibt Windows Server 2022 seit noch nicht so lange.
Hier, seit letztem Jahr.
Das kenne ich mich aber nicht mit aus, weil ich jegliche Windows Server Geschichten ignoriere.
Hat jemand, nee, nicht seit 2021, hat jemand von euch die große Ehre, Windows Server zu administrieren?
Ist das jetzt eigentlich, das ist Windows 10?
Nein, dann 2022 sieht nicht aus wie Windows 11.
Windows Server 2022 sieht so weit, ich weiß aus, wie Windows Server so aussieht.
Auch mit diesem hässlichen Oldschool-Assistent und sowas.
Ja, genau.
Das ist so Paynes-Champ.
Wir haben noch mal uns in einem Stream Windows Server angeguckt und haben ein paar Basic-Sachen versucht einzurichten.
Ich bin da halb durchgedreht dabei.
Da ploppt laufen irgendwas auf.
Du musst in ein Assistent durchklicken.
So Basic-Features wie Telnet musst du dann erst mal Telnet-Feature hinzufügen und sowas.
Also ganz ehrlich, für jemand, der hauptsächlich im Linux-Umfeld zu Hause ist, ist Windows Server ganz, ganz großer Rost.
Aber ich denke mal, dass für richtige Hardcore-Windows-Admins und Windows-Fans das umgedreht ähnlich ist.
Ich glaube, wenn du irgendeinen jahrelangen Windows-Only-Admin, der da auch voll dahinter steht und das richtig geil findet,
vor irgendeinen Ubuntu-Server setzt, mit Minimal-Installation,
ja, der hat wahrscheinlich auch nicht so viel Spaß.
Ja, so.
Lukas, danke für den Sub.
Früher haben Brenner war mega teuer.
Ich hatte damals einen MP3-Player.
Ich glaube, das wird man gar nicht mehr finden.
Sekunde, ich guck mal kurz auf dem Handy.
Das Ding muss ich euch zeigen.
Das fand ich mega nice.
Heute wird man sich darüber wegkecken.
Hab ich bei Amazon gekauft.
MP3.
Gucken, ob ich das noch finde.
Also überhaupt so weit zurück geht.
Nö.
Gibt's nicht mal mehr.
Ich habe mir einen MP3-Player gekauft.
Der konnte nicht nur MP3s abspielen.
Der hatte so ein Mini-Mini-Mini-Display.
Der von 2003 oder so.
Noch viel, viel kleiner.
Und ich habe tatsächlich teilweise darauf Videos geguckt.
Das war, das konntest du nicht erkennen.
Also das Display war so groß,
du konntest dir quasi das Display ins Auge stecken.
Und das hat quasi gerade mal
dein Blickfeld von links nach rechts ausgefüllt.
So klein war das Display.
Ja, Videos kann man es nicht wirklich nennen.
Bewegte Bilder geguckt.
Aber ein interessantes Stellenangebot
in Frankfurt gesehen.
Wo wohnt man da am besten?
Hast du Empfehlungen, wenn man dich nicht auskennt,
wohnt man da plötzlich?
Ja, gut.
Das wirst du wahrscheinlich mitkriegen,
wenn du in der Nähe vom Flughafen wohnst.
Ich würde es ein bisschen davon abhängig machen,
wo du arbeitest.
Äh, arbeitest.
Weil Frankfurt ist groß.
Nur weil man in Frankfurt irgendwo wohnt
und in Frankfurt arbeitet,
ist es nicht automatisch gesagt,
dass man da easy hinkommt.
Die bauen gerade einen neuen Stadtteil in Frankfurt.
Ansonsten, ich kann hier leider nicht so viel zu sagen,
weil ich wohne ja selbst nicht direkt in Frankfurt.
Du hast ein CD-Laufwerk drin.
Weird Champ.
Ja, das liegt aber an zwei Sachen.
Das liegt nicht daran, dass Blu-ray so geil ist,
sondern an den Streamingdiensten
und am Internet in Deutschland.
Auf der anderen Seite ist halt auch fraglich,
ob man das überhaupt wirklich braucht.
Also, was haben 50, 60 Mbit,
haben doch so Filme von Blu-ray, ne?
Also, aber ich glaube immer noch,
Blu-ray hat immer noch H264-Encoding.
Also sprich, Streamingdienste mit niedrigerer Bitrate
und besserem Encoding,
könnte darauf was ähnliches kommen.
Für Langzeitspeicher sind optische noch recht gut.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Für Langzeitspeicher stehen die Leute im Business-Umfeld
auch heute immer noch auf Magnet-Tapes.
Die Double-TV, danke für den Zapp.
Hat sie nicht durchgesetzt, also HD, DVD oder so.
Tja, Grip. Blu-ray ist immer H265?
Okay, na dann.
Wo ist jetzt erstmal den Chat fertig,
hier übers Skippen, Leute?
Ich muss ja sowas, was, was, was einkaufen.
Und dann gucken wir ein paar Videos.
Kann man das anklicken?
What if I told you there exists some...
Ja, gibt es noch.
Würde ich nie machen, aber gibt es noch.
Warum Telen in 2022 benutzen,
weil es der einfachste Weg ist,
irgendwelche Services zu checken, ob sie offen sind.
Und HTTP zu testen ist, glaube ich, nicht einfacher,
als einfach ein Telnet aufzumachen.
Telnet?
Wobei, ich habe keine Vm an.
Telnet machst du einfach telnet, google.de, get-slash
und du weißt, ob ein HTTP-Server ist.
Ja, PowerShell-Gedöns, wer verwendet sowas denn schon?
Seid ihr jetzt nicht von mir?
Das stimmt, es ist mir bei Amazon Video auch schon aufgefallen,
dass gerade, wenn es dunkel ist,
das ist natürlich auch am schwierigsten für Encoder,
dass du teilweise ziemliches gepixelt siehst.
Ja, ja.
Madness.
Massive Subscription hier, Dankeschön.
Tja, Netcan unter Windows wird aber noch schwieriger.
Gut, WSL mittlerweile.
Okay, wir haben es geschafft, Leute.
Was haben wir denn für Videos?
Ich habe einfach noch ein paar angeklickt vorhin.
Ach so, ich habe mein eigenes Video durchlaufen lassen
für die View-Time, versteht sich.
Wer es noch nicht gesehen hat, ich habe heute tatsächlich
zur Abwechslung mal ein neues Video hochgeladen.
Ich hoffe, das nächste Video braucht nicht wieder so lang.
Der heikle Wandel der VPN-Placements,
das gucken wir uns jetzt an, Leute.
Platz 20 auf Trending.
Hacky, danke für den Zapp.
Und danach kaufen wir noch schnell was ein.
Ich brauche nämlich noch ein paar Sachen.
Übrigens, mein Amazon-Basket kann ich dir helfen.
Habe ich bestellt?
Habe ich nicht bestellt?
So, das gucken wir uns jetzt mal mit.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was der dazu sagt.
Also meine Meinung zu VPNs und VPN-Placements kennt ihr.
Meine Meinung zu VPNs ist, in der Regel braucht man sie nicht.
Und die Leute versprechen sich da viel mehr davon,
als es einem enthalten kann.
Für manche Anwendungszwecke ist VPN sinnvoll.
Und die Placements sind teilweise wahnsinnig überzogen.
Also es gibt Channels, die gucke ich gerne.
Simon Dan zum Beispiel, der macht auch öfters VPN-Placements.
Denke ich mir immer, ich gucke deinen Channel ja wirklich gerne.
Aber die VPN-Placements, da habe ich das Gefühl,
er weiß auch nicht genau wovon er redet.
Er liest einfach seinen Text vor.
Ja, wenn man es als Werbung sieht und das ignoriert,
dann ja, ist das okay.
Aber ich glaube, den meisten ist nicht so ganz klar,
dass das zum größten Teil ziemlicher Blödsinn ist,
was die VPN-Anbieter da verzapfen,
was dann immer erzählt wird von wegen Privacy und sonst was.
Es ist nicht privater, über einen VPN zu surfen als ohne VPN.
Das einzige, was der Anbieter nicht mehr direkt mitbekommt,
ist deine Absender-IP.
Aber das ist überhaupt kein Thema.
Die Absender-IP braucht ja kein Mensch, um euch zu tracken.
Wozu?
Absender-IP ist sowas von overrated, outdated,
Chibane, niemand braucht mehr IP-Adressen.
So, gucken wir mal an, was er dazu sagt.
Es ist gesund, wenn man bei der Art häufiger Werbung
und dauerhaften Rabatten im hohen zweistelligen Bereich
langsam skeptisch wird, ob das, was einem da präsentiert wird,
wirklich etwas taugt.
Und mir ging es da nicht anders.
Ich kam auch nicht, um hinzubemerken,
dass Werbung für verschiedene, aber in ihrer Anzahl
wenige VPN-Anbieter auf einem guten Weg sind, das null.
Im Prinzip wollte ich grad sagen, es ist ExpressVPN, NordVPN.
Die zwei, oder?
Leute, fällt euch noch einen VPN-Anbieter ein.
Es ist ExpressVPN, es ist NordVPN.
Wer macht denn sonst noch?
SharkVPN hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Nein, nein, wer Werbung macht?
Wer Werbung macht?
Hacksurf? Cyber hab ich schon nie gehört als Werbung.
Eigentlich hauptsächlich NordVPN. NordVPN ist besonders hartnäckig.
Was? Tunnel? Bier? Beer?
Auch nie gehört.
OtonVPN, das kann sein, dass ich das schon mal gehört hab.
Es gibt so viele.
Warum gibt's von denen so viele?
Okay, gucken wir uns mal weiter.
Blankoplacement auf dieser Plattform zu werden.
Schauen wir uns also mal an, was...
Das ist das neue Raid Shadow Legends.
... mit diesen Produkten auf sich hat
und welche Entwicklung die Werbung für sie hinter sich hat.
Neben dem Fakt, dass VPN-Anbieter offenbar mehr
als alle anderen Werbetreibenden auf YouTube gewillt sind,
Produktplatzierungen wie Kugelschreiber auf einer Messe rauszuballern,
hat es noch ein...
Ich hätte auch fast was mit NordVPN gemacht.
Allerdings...
Das ist eh auch wieder geil.
Also, die haben mich angeschrieben mit der üblichen Geschichte,
so wie einen diese Anbieter alle anschreiben.
Hey, Max, wir finden deinen Channel so toll.
Möchtest du nicht Placement für uns machen?
So...
Dann hab ich tatsächlich mal gesagt, hier...
Dann hab ich meine Manager weitergeschickt
und hab gesagt, hier, vielleicht...
Können wir da irgendwas machen.
Da haben wir uns mit denen was überlegt
und wir waren uns schon einig.
Also, wir hatten schon...
Ja, die Bezahlung war in Ordnung.
Die war jetzt nicht super krass, aber die war schon echt okay.
Und wir waren uns auch einig.
Auch ungefähr über den Content und was es Geld gibt.
Das war, glaub ich, sogar mit Twitter-Posts und allem dabei.
Und...
Als wir uns einig waren,
kommt dann auf einmal der NordVPN-Typ an und meint so,
Max...
Ich hab da ein Video auf deinem Channel gefunden.
Das müsstest du löschen,
sonst kommt die Kooperation nicht zustande.
Dann hab ich gesagt, ja, dann kommt die Kooperation halt nicht zustande,
weil ich lösche bestimmt keine Videos.
Aber, wie das bei diesen ganzen Marketing-Läden so ist,
wir sind uns da nicht einig geworden
und zwei Wochen später
kam wieder NordVPN-Anfrage von irgendeiner anderen Werbeagentur.
Die reden miteinander auch nicht.
Ja, da mach ich halt nix mit NordVPN.
Ganz ehrlich, ich lösche keine Videos.
Ich hab ihnen sogar angeboten, ich kann das thematisieren
in dem Video
so nach dem Motto hier, ihr wisst ja,
ich bin da skeptisch, was VPNs angeht,
und ich hab da auch schon Videos drüber gemacht,
aber es gibt Punkte, dafür sind VPNs tatsächlich sinnvoll.
Das hätt ich sogar gemacht.
Aber das wollten sie nicht.
Tja.
Und dann halt nicht.
Ich bin nicht für die Kohle irgendwie großartig angewiesen.
Dann habt ihr Pech.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns den Grama fertig an.
Das stimmt ja.
Das stimmt.
Da hab ich mir so noch gar keine Gedanken drüber gemacht,
aber das stimmt schon.
VPN-Werbung kannst du überall machen.
Ja.
Also, Vsauce kenn ich, Team Harrison kenn ich nicht,
das sieht aus wie so ein Familien-Channel.
Quer über den gesamten Themenkosmos
wird für dieser Anbieter Werbung gemacht,
und dann verwundert es auch nicht,
dass zumindest Teile dieses Kosmos nicht ganz genau wissen,
wofür sie da eigentlich Werbung machen.
Und wie leider üblich, das Briefing einfach unkritisch ablesen.
Ja, das hab ich auch bei manchen in Eintracht,
dass sie das ablesen.
... einen bisher einzigartigen Drift hingelegt,
der vielleicht sogar am Ende etwas Positives bedeutet.
Aber fangen wir vorne an.
Werbung für VPN-Anbieter
hat sich in den letzten Jahren stark gewandelt.
Alles fing an mit dem Geschäft mit der Angst.
Ja, ist ja immer noch so.
Dass ihr ohne VPN unterwegs seid,
dass einfach jeder eure Daten abfangen kann,
eure Passwörter einfach so aus seinem öffentlichen Netz...
Ja, ist ja immer noch so.
Das ist ja teilweise immer noch so.
Gerade die YouTuber, die gar keinen Plan von der Materie haben,
die erzählen so einen Blödsinn immer noch.
... Netzwerk fischt und dann mit eurem Knuddel zu kauen
und alle eure hart erspielten Rosen rausballert.
Gibt es Knuddel überhaupt noch?
Solche und ähnlich apokalyptische Szenarien...
Lange nichts gehört.
... wurden noch vor etwa einem Jahr
mit Window-Color an die Höhlenmauern gemalt.
Mittlerweile klingt Werbung für VPN-Anbieter ganz anders.
Ja, äh...
Manche Serien, die ich mag,
gibt's nur im australischen Netflix.
Da muss ich dann VPN benutzen, damit ich das gucken kann.
Ja, das ist ja wahr.
Ein starkes Gefälle zwischen diesen beiden Aussagen irgendwie.
Und das ist dieser positive Twisting.
Das ist ja tatsächlich
eines der wenigen wirklich sinnvollen Anwendungsgebiete für VPNs.
... ich meine.
Offenbar sind vielen YouTubern ihre Integrität wichtiger
als die Hörigkeit gegenüber Werbetreibenden.
Denn an dieser ersten digitalen Götterdämmerung
war leider fast gar nichts wahr.
Ja, aber auch nur, aber auch nur...
Ich bin mir da gar nicht so sicher, ob das so
Selbsterkenntnis ist mancher großen YouTube-Channels,
sondern eher, dass die Zuschauer das mittlerweile checken
und das zur negative Feedback gibt für den YouTuber,
wenn er so Blödsinn erzählt.
Eine VPN-Verbindung ist, simpel ausgedrückt,
eine optionale Station für den Datenverkehr,
die dafür sorgt, dass Anfragen vom Nutzer
erst durch den VPN-Service geschleust,
dort mit einer neuen IP-Adresse versehen,
und dann dem Internetanbieter übergeben wird,
um die getätigten Anfragen auszuführen.
Das auch dafür, dass...
Es ist okay.
Die Erklärung ist gut.
Für jemand, der... keine Ahnung.
Also ich meine nicht ihn, sondern die Leute,
die gucken, ist die Erklärung gut.
Natürlich benutzt man trotzdem weiterhin seinen Internetanbieter,
weil ansonsten kommt man ja gar nicht von sich daheim
zum VPN-Anbieter, weil, was meint ihr,
über welche Kabel und welche Router das hier geht,
um zu seinem VPN-Anbieter zu kommen?
Naja, von seinem Internetanbieter natürlich,
von seinem Provider und seinen Peering-Partnern
und alles, was auf dem Weg ist.
Aber die Erklärung ist gut.
Der Internetanbieter nicht mehr die einzelnen Domains sieht,
zu denen man Anfragen schickt,
sondern nur noch die Kommunikation mit dem VPN-Service.
Die Seiten, die man so aufruft,
können einen durch die IP auch nicht mehr genau zuordnen,
dadurch dieses Verfahren verschiedene Leute
über dieselbe oder wechselnde IPs unterwegs sind.
Letzteres ist kein großer Gewicht.
Alternativ, alternativ,
bei Light, bei Unity Made, bei Vodafone
hat man auch eine IP mit mehreren Leuten.
Da Webseiten verschiedenste Möglichkeiten abseits der IP haben,
Zugriffe auf ein einzigartiges Endgerät zurückzuverfolgen.
Aber wer seinem Internetanbieter nicht traut
und dem verheimlichen will, auf welchen Seiten man unterwegs ist,
der kann einen VPN-Anbieter nutzen
und stattdessen dem diese Daten geben.
Denn das ist das große Dilemma.
Das habe ich auch damals schon im Video gesagt
und da würde ich mir echt mal interessieren,
was die VPN-Anbieter darauf sagen.
Weil eines der Dinge, was jeder VPN-Anbieter sagt ist,
sie loggen nichts, sie haben die Daten nicht
und sie geben die Daten auch nicht raus.
Wo ich mich mal fragte, Moment, wenn die Daten ich habe,
dann könnte die ja gar nicht rausgeben.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das ist das,
ich wollte sagen, das Papier nicht wert, auf dem es steht.
Aber das stimmt nicht, weil das steht ja auf keinem Papier.
Aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Das ist das Papier nicht wert, auf dem es steht.
Da kann man jetzt was drauf geben oder es auch sein lassen.
Da muss man sich überlegen, ob man der Sache traut.
Ja, und selbst wenn es bei manchen VPN-Anbietern wirklich so ist
oder mal im einen Verfahren so war,
muss man sich überlegen, ob man da wirklich was drauf geben will.
Weil im Ernst, du kannst das nicht nachvollziehen.
Also, du hast keine Chance.
Du kannst das genauso wenig nachvollziehen,
wie ob morgen die Bahn pünktlich kommt.
Also du weißt das nicht.
Können viel sagen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Die Bahn sagt auch, sie sind pünktlich und sind nicht pünktlich.
Also wenn jemand wirklich Ziel hat, anonym zu sein,
rein für Surfen,
dann soll er wirklich den Tor Browser oder sowas in der Richtung verwenden.
Wobei es ja auch schon die ein oder anderen Enttarnungen gab.
Aber über Tor ist halt Streaming nicht gut.
Also wenn man jetzt Sicherheitskopien laden möchte
von irgendwelchen Newsnet Seiten oder sonst was,
dann ist das mit Tor nichts.
Mehrere VPN Clients, geht das?
Ja, das geht.
Hängt ein bisschen vom Anbieter ab,
hängt ein bisschen davon ab, wie das mit seiner Software funktioniert.
Aber prinzipiell geht das.
90% aller Turnouts sind von...
Ich weiß nicht, ob es 90% sind, aber ich weiß,
dass gerade die Exit-Notes
wohl gerne von irgendwelchen Geheimdiensten betrieben werden.
Ja, VPN über Tor geht auch.
Aber das bringt dir dann genauso wenig für Streaming was.
Es gibt sich Möglichkeiten.
Du kannst mehrere VPN-Anbieter verwenden.
Du kannst, wenn du es wirklich,
also ganz im Ernst, wenn ich nicht möchte,
dass angenommen man macht irgendwas im Internet,
was jetzt nicht gerade illegales Streaming ist,
von Sachen, die man eigentlich nicht gucken sollte,
ohne dafür zu bezahlen,
dann würde ich das aus einer Kombination machen
von VPN, Proxy-Servern
und am allerbesten ist es,
wenn man andere Maschinen hat,
wo man per SSH drauf kann und von dort weitermacht,
weil dann ist...
Ja, man kann es beliebig kompliziert machen.
Irgendwann ist es halt nur noch Schneckentempo.
Was meint ihr denn, warum Botnetze so beliebt sind,
um komische Dinger zu treiben?
Oder warum teilweise
jahrelang irgendwelche ollen Dinger im Internet stehen
und da schon quasi Gott und die Welt drauf ist,
von China-Chinesen bis Russen und alles,
weil es praktisch ist,
einen Ausgangspunkt zu haben im Internet,
den man nicht bezahlt hat.
Weil, wenn du Sachen bezahlst
und du bezahlst deinen VPN-Anbieter ja auch am Ende,
ist das in der Regel eine ziemlich gute Möglichkeit,
zurückzuverfolgen, wer das denn jetzt benutzt hat.
Ja, man kann es dann über Kryptowährungen und Gedöns bezahlen,
aber am besten ist natürlich was,
wenn man einen Ausgangspunkt hat,
den man nicht bezahlt hat,
weil der einem gar nicht gehört,
weil er vielleicht irgendjemand anderem gehört.
Das ist natürlich klar.
Da fällt nichts auf einen zurück.
Oder wenn du im WLAN bist,
bei irgendeinem offenen Hotspot,
wenn du im WLAN bist,
bei irgendwelchen Leuten, die schlecht gesichert haben,
das ist natürlich am besten,
weil dann führt auch nicht der Bezahlprozess zu dir zurück.
Stimmt das wirklich,
dass das Internet Darkweb ist?
Keine Ahnung.
Darkweb heißt ja erst mal nur,
dass du das nicht so einfach über Suchmaschinen findest,
weil das über irgendwelche Onion-Adressen
oder hast du nicht gesehen geht.
Oder sag mal so, wenn man sagt, was Dark...
Was definiert man als Darkweb?
Das ganze Onion-Zeug
oder auch Sachen, die Suchmaschinen nicht erreichen können,
weil Suchmaschinen können verdammt viel nicht erreichen,
wenn man sie nicht für einen anderen Grund gründen.
Ah ja.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das 90% sind.
Es kommt mir ein bisschen viel vor, ehrlich gesagt.
Wenn man jetzt einfach nur sagen würde,
das sind die, die quasi absichtlich das verschleiern wollen.
Man könnte nämlich auch genauso gut sagen,
das stimmt nicht, weil das, was Dark ist
und nicht gefunden werden will,
dann ist das ein bisschen besser als es.
Dann muss man es auch nicht mitzählen.
Ist ein bisschen philosophische Frage.
Einfach ein Software im PaySafe?
Ja, es gibt verschiedene Varianten.
Das ist mir auch klar.
Aber die beste Variante ist,
das ist natürlich auch die am wenigsten erlaubte Variante,
wenn man irgendeinen Ausgangspunkt hat,
den man gar nicht bezahlen muss.
Sei es Public WLAN Hotspots, ungesicherte WLANs,
irgendwelche anderen Sachen,
schlecht gesicherte Server im Internet.
Wenn man so was hat,
ist das natürlich der optimale Ausgangspunkt.
Deswegen sind ja auch Bordnetze so beliebt.
Der optimale Ausgangspunkt für irgendwelche komischen Aktivitäten,
weil man so gut wie nicht zurückverfolgt werden kann.
Und darauf zugreifen dann über VPN, über Proxy,
über weitere Zwischenrelays per SSH.
Dann ist die Sache eigentlich nahezu unmöglich,
dass man da irgendjemand findet.
Wenn man es natürlich nicht verkackt,
wenn man irgendeinen VPN benutzt
und nebenbei noch einen Rechner hat mit einem offenen Browser,
wo man auf seinem YouTube-Channel eingeloggt ist
oder bei Twitter eingeloggt ist
und das quasi dann zuordnenbar ist,
das ist mal selbst dran schuld.
Aber ich kann es euch nur noch mal empfehlen,
ihr müsst einfach nichts Illegales machen.
Wenn man so will, wäre jedes WordPress-Backend-Darkweb.
Genau, weil man nicht darauf zugreifen kann.
Deswegen, das ist reine Definitionssache.
Wenn du sagst, alles, was in irgendeiner Weise
über mehrere Zwischenhops mit dem Internet verbunden ist,
wenn du das alles mitzählst,
dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass 90% der Sachen
nicht indiziert werden können.
Ich meine, es gibt petabyteweise irgendwelche Backend-Datenbanken,
File Storage, Archive, was auch immer.
Also dann, dass das 90% sind, ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Gibt ein gutes Einladungsvideo vom CCC zu Darknet auf YouTube.
Hast du mal einen Link?
Wenn das nicht so ein 1,5-Stunden-Video ist,
könnte man es dir sogar angucken.
Falls du was hast, schick mal.
Ah, hier, direkt am Start, Alter, geht ja.
Kaffeefahrt ins Darknet.
36 Minuten, mal gucken.
Mal gucken, vielleicht gucken wir uns das nachher an.
Die Hackergrills, ich sehe es gerade.
Ja, können wir uns nachher vielleicht angucken.
So, jetzt gucken wir aber erst mal das Video fertig.
Ja, die behaupten viel über den Tag alles.
Na klar, die wollen ja nicht dichtgemacht werden,
weil wahrscheinlich in den meisten Ländern,
müssen wir mal gucken, wo die sitzen,
weil die Polizei das trotzdem gerne hat, wenn man mit ihnen spricht.
Und was in diesen Werbungen natürlich auch nicht erwähnt wird,
dass es kein Zaubertrick der Webseiten oder Internetanbieter
völlig unvorbereitet trifft.
Wenn ihr Pech habt, blockiert eine wichtige Webseite
oder gleich euer ganzer Internetanbieter die IP-Adressen des VPN.
Viele dieser Sachen hat Tom Scott.
Ist mir jetzt in letzter Zeit eigentlich nicht mehr aufgefallen,
dass irgendwelche deutschen Internetanbieter VPN-Verbindungen,
fällt euch da was Aktuelles ein?
Also Netflix weiß ich, aber das ist ja kein Internet,
das ist ja quasi der Content-Auslieferer am Ende.
Die sind da gerade ein bisschen hinterher.
Aber Internetanbieter fällt mir jetzt gerade aktuell nichts ein.
Hab ich mich auch nicht darüber informiert in letzter Zeit,
muss ich sagen.
Fällt auf, könnt ihr mal in den Chat schreiben, ob euch da was bekannt ist aktuell?
Sieht man die Domain bei HTTPS?
Ich glaube nicht, über DNS-Anfragen kannst du die sehen.
Aber in HTTPS siehst du die Domain?
Eigentlich nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, weil HTTPS ist TLS auf Layer 3-Ebene.
Und dementsprechend siehst du Protokolle da drüber nicht mehr.
Du siehst keinen.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich glaube, wir können das ausprobieren.
Wir können das, wir probieren das jetzt aus.
Easy.
Sekunde, ich war mal kurz Musiker, wir probieren das jetzt aus.
Ich, ich bin mir relativ sicher, du siehst das nicht.
Werden wir gleich sehen, probieren wir jetzt aus.
Erstmal kurz meine VM starten.
Nee, nee, das siehst du nicht.
Das ist TLS auf Layer 3 und dementsprechend siehst du,
was Protokoll drüber geht nicht.
Ja, DNS siehst du, über DNS Auflösung kannst du sehen beim Provider.
Aber du siehst nicht wirklich die, äh, den, den, den, Getrequest bzw.
auch gar nicht die Seite, auf, auf die das geht.
Du siehst die IP und du siehst den DNS Request, da kannst du ganz gut
Rückschlüsse drauf ziehen.
Aber hinter einer IP sind ja oftmals mehrere Sachen.
die IP und du siehst in den S-Request da kannst du ganz gut Rückschlüsse drauf ziehen aber hinter einer
IP sind ja oftmals mehrere Sachen also es muss nicht unbedingt sein. So wir probieren das jetzt
einfach mal aus also. Bei Wireshark. Muss man das nicht als Route starten? Oder man packt sich in die
passende passende Gruppe rein. So also Wireshark. Firefox. Wobei wir brauchen noch nicht mal ein
Firefox. Wir brauchen einfach nur. Wir brauchen einfach nur ein Curl und gut ist. So. Curl,
ATTPS, google.de. MonkaS, Alter! Was geht denn da gerade im Hintergrund ab, Alter?
Wo ist mein. Wo ist mein HTTP Request?
Wo? Äh? Wo? Wo zum? Ich sehe nicht. Da? Wo?
Das müsst ihr eigentlich als HTTP. Ach Quatsch! Nein! Ich mache ja kein HTTP Request. Oh man!
Es ist jetzt doch genau das was ich eben gesagt habe wie es ist. So ist es doch auch. Guck mal
man sieht nämlich kein HTTP Request. Man sieht bloß irgendwelche TCP Verbindungen. So. SYN.
Welcher ist es denn? Kann man hier Port oder so einpländen lassen?
Wir bräuchten einen TCP SYN Package. Ich finde mein Request nicht all das zu viel.
Alter! What the fuck? Ist da unterwegs im Hintergrund? Hier! Da! TLS. Hier! Das ist mein Request.
Das ist er. Da ist er. Das ist mein TLS Request. Da siehst du nichts. Follow TCP Stream.
So. Da siehst du nichts. Du siehst alles verschlüsselt. Das ist zu AWS. Dann blicke
ich nicht mehr durch. Es ist so viel los auf meinem Interface. Das ist mein TLS Request.
Womit bin ich das überhaupt? Hab ich denn für eine IP? Nee ach ich kann ja nach meiner
IP filtern. Mensch ganz einfach. Source. Hier. Da sind wir. Google. Hier. Da sind wir. Das
sieht gut aus. Google. So. Und das ist der Ack zu Google wahrscheinlich. Nee das nicht.
Warum ist denn so viel los? Wo ist denn jetzt mein Traffic? Alter. Was geht hier eigentlich
gerade im Hintergrund ab in meinem Netzwerk? Hier. Das da. Das da. Das da. Hier. Das da.
Das ist mein Request. Das ist mein Request an Google. Und das ist von Anfang an ist
der Krempel verschlüsselt. Man kann jetzt noch hier irgendwie reingucken. Client. Hello.
Ganz oben steht Google. Ja Moment. Es steht der DNS Request steht drinne. Ach tatsächlich.
Tatsächlich sieht man echt. Wusste ich nicht. Guck du mal da. Welcher welcher ist das hier
von? Die Domain brauchst du wahrscheinlich fürs Zertifikat oder? Weil der muss dem ja
mitschicken wo er hin will, dass er über SNI das richtige Zertifikat rausfügt. Wobei
es hätte auch sein können, dass es schon alles verschlüsselt passiert. Keine Ahnung. Welches
dieser Packages ist das jetzt? Wahrscheinlich. Wo steht Google drin? Das erste. Das wirst
er nicht. Ich weiß nicht. Zumindest man erkennt. Das ist wusste ich nicht. Ich hätte gedacht,
das ist eigentlich alles verschlüsselt. Das ist nicht das erste. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Es ist aber auch wurscht. Es ist auch egal. Wir sehen, dass es nicht verschlüsselt ist.
Das ist interessant. Ich habe Leute, ich habe gedacht, das wäre aber gut, wenn er das fürs
Zertifikat braucht, ergibt das natürlich Sinn. Okay, gut, das ist was gelernt. Wo kommen
eigentlich die ganzen RTMP Pakete her? Das ist Twitch. Das ist das ist vom Haus. Das
ist nicht von AVM. Das hier sind Twitch. Moment. Das hier sind Twitch Packages. Von
meinem Host. Das hier die ganzen RTMP. Das ist Twitch. Das bekommt er mit, weil meine
AVM gebridged ist an das Host Interface. Ja, jetzt gucken wir das Video fertig. Ewig gebrauchter.
Und auch wenn sehr viele Webseiten diese Verschlüsselung nutzen, tun es noch nicht alle. Seinen eigenen
VPN-Service zu bauen ist übrigens weit weniger komplex, als man annehmen könnte und dazu
auch noch wesentlich günstiger als ein Abo bei einem dieser Anbieter. Es gibt gute, aber
weit weniger Gründe als beworben, sich hin und wieder mal über einen VPN zu verbinden.
Wenn man eingesehen hat, dass der Inkognito-Modus des Browsers einfach nur keinen Verlauf anlegt,
aber einen in keinster Weise anonym macht, wenn man seine Aktivität in öffentlichen
Netzwerken lieber einem VPN-Dienst als einem Netzwerk-Administratoren zeigen will oder wenn
man Geoblocking umgehen will. Und dieser letzte Punkt ist der letzte echte Strohhalm, mit
dem man VPNs noch einigermaßen nachvollziehbar an die Masse bewerben kann. Das ist alles,
was übrig geblieben ist. Und ganz ehrlich, das finde ich okay. Naja, nicht nur. Also
ein weiterer Punkt, den ich auch noch halbwegs sinnvoll finde, ist, wenn man öffentliche
WLANs verwendet, aber verwendet man so oft öffentliche WLANs, und wenn man das macht,
ja vielleicht tut es auch irgendeinen Proxy oder aber ein eigenes VPN, aber dafür ist
es vielleicht auch noch sinnvoll.
Mir persönlich kaum egaler sein könnte, aber wenn Leute davon einen Nutzen haben, dann
können sie das so machen. Was mich nur stört, ist, diejenigen, die vor Tom Scott VPNs als
Allheilmittel gegen fiktive Sicherheitslücken angepriesen haben und sie jetzt als Netflix
Hack bewerben, haben das in ihren Videos nie aufgearbeitet.
Die wollen bestimmt keine Leute noch darauf aufmerksam machen, dass sie einen Blödsinn
erzählt haben.
Die haben es einfach übernommen, aber nicht geprüft haben und es jetzt besser machen
wollen. Aktuell fangen einige VPN-Anbieter auch an, in den Virenschutzmarkt einzusteigen,
was die eigene Seriosität vielleicht nicht gerade erhöht. Aber dazu habe ich ja schon
was gemacht. Versteht mich nicht falsch, es ist sehr gut, dass wir nicht mehr von Military
Grade Encryption und aus der Luft gesch...
Leute, wisst ihr, dass ihr auch Military Grade Encryption verwendet? Taktäglich verwendet
ihr Military Grade Encryption.
Euch ist es vielleicht gar nicht klar.
Genau, ihr verwendet AES und AES ist Military Grade Encryption.
Ach, das war der mit dem Drucker-Scam-Video. Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum mir der Kanal
empfohlen wurde.
Moin, Patrick. Massive.
Schweizer sind da. Ja, AES, ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher. War AES nicht sogar vom Militär
ursprünglich ausgeschrieben?
Ich kann mich über diesen Auswahlprozess, ich krieg das aus dem Kopf nicht mehr zusammen.
Aber wisst ihr, was lustig ist? Damals hat die Telekom auch was eingereicht für AES.
Also AES ist ja quasi jetzt der Standard, aber die haben ja explizit einen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus
in so einem Wettbewerb gesucht für diesen neuen Standard. Und AES, beziehungsweise das,
was jetzt AES geworden ist, hatte halt gewonnen. Und die Telekom hat auch einen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus
damals eingereicht für, da steht das hier drinnen, AES Telekom Wettbewerb. Die Telekom
hat damals auch einen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus eingereicht, der sich Magenta nannte, genau.
Die sind aber schon in der ersten Runde ausgeschieden, weil beim quasi ersten Blick drauf man festgestellt
hat, das funktioniert nicht.
Und ihr verwendet jeden Tag AES und AES ist Military Create Encryption, weil, das steht
hier oben glaube ich auch, AES 192 und AES 256 sind in den USA für staatliche Dokumente
mit höchstem Geheimhaltungsgrad zugelassen. Ich glaube mehr Military Create Encryption
geht nicht und das verwendet ihr jeden Tag. Und übrigens DES, Fun Fact zu DES, ich hoffe,
das ist noch aktuell, was ich jetzt hier erzähle, DES oder 3 DES, wo man das dann einfach mehrfach
hintereinander gemacht hat, wurde nie geknackt meines Wissens nach. Zumindest, ich gebe zu,
das ist schon ein paar Jahre her, wo ich mich da ein bisschen mit beschäftigt habe. Aber
danach, der Vorgänger von AES, das ist glaube ich von IBM gewesen, DES, der wurde nie geknackt.
War das nicht von IBM? Ja, das war nicht von IBM. Die wurden nie geknackt. Das Problem
dabei ist nur, dass DES von 1975 ist, mit einer Schlüssellänge von 56 Bit. 56 Bit Schlüssellänge
ist heute halt ein bisschen kurz und du kannst DES halt einfach durchdurchprobieren knacken.
DES wurde nie geknackt. Also, man spricht ja davon, sobald du in der Lage bist, von
einer Verschlüsselung, die Zahl der Versuche, die du brauchst, quasi nennenswert zu verringern
im Vergleich zu einfach Bloodforce, dann ist das Ding angreifbar. Oder wenn es gar so sehr
verringert wird, dann kannst du sogar sagen, es ist geknackt. Also, in der Regel ist es
ja so, du musst, aber du hast was verschlüsselt, mit einem Passwort, symmetrisch, das ist ja
alles symmetrische Verschlüsselung, du hast was verschlüsselt mit einem Passwort, symmetrisch
und du kennst das Passwort nicht. Sonst ist das Ganze ja natürlich langweilig. Dann musst
du theoretisch nicht alle Passwörter durchprobieren, sondern statistisch gesehen musst du 50
Prozent der möglichen Passwörter durchprobieren. Weil, naja, nach 50 Prozent hast du dann im
Durchschnitt halt das Richtige gefunden. Jetzt kommen natürlich die finnigen Leute
an, ja, Max, dann nehme ich als Passwort einfach zzzzzzzzzzzzzzz, das probiert man ja als letztes
durch und dementsprechend bin ich besonders sicher, das funktioniert auch nicht. Aber
wenn du irgendwas findest, was das deutlich verringert, diese Zahl im Vergleich zum sinnlosen
Prude Force und nach 50 Prozent der durchprobierten Sachen hat man es, dann hast du was gefunden,
dass das ganz angreifbar ist. Aber, das hört sich jetzt vielleicht nicht so krass an, aber
man muss sich mal überlegen, was das bedeutet. Also, zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt ein Passwort
hat mit 26 Zeichen, also klein a bis klein z, ja, mit, keine Ahnung, nehmen wir einfach
ein 18-stelliges Passwort, dann hast du das hier mit 25 Nullen hinten dran an möglichen
Kombinationen. Und, das durchzuprobieren, dauert auch mit dem schnellsten, krassesten
Computer der Welt lange. Und lange ist wahrscheinlich so lange, dass wahrscheinlich die Sonne,
die Erde, wobei bei 18, bei 18 Stellen bin ich mir noch nicht so sehen. 18 Stellen sind
noch nicht so krass. Aber sobald es länger wird, da sieht man übrigens auch schön dran,
so, 19 Stellen, da kommt halt immer noch eine Null hinten dran und da bist du irgendwann
in, ach ja, das ist ein schönes Bild, genau, da bist du irgendwann in Bereichen, da sind
wahrscheinlich schon alle Atome im Universum zerfallen und kaputt und was auch immer, dann
hast du, bist du immer noch am Rechnen. Ja, ok. Komm mal, number of characters, wenn du
nur lowercase verwendest, guck mal, das war mein Beispiel, lowercase, 18 Buchstaben, du
brauchst 2 Millionen Jahre, gut Leute, ich hab eigentlich ganz gut geschätzt, also in
2 Millionen Jahren gibt es das Sonnensystem wahrscheinlich noch und die Sonne, die gibt
es auch noch. Man ist sich ja dann nicht ganz einig, in welchem Zeitraum das passiert,
aber irgendwann wird ja die Sonne sich aufblähen und irgendwann mal die Erde wahrscheinlich
verschlucken, da weiß man nicht, aber man ist dann auf jeden Fall nicht mehr dabei und
kann sich das angucken. Aber 2 Millionen Jahre, da könnte man sagen, das ist noch so, da
ist das hier so ungefähr zumindest Sonnensystem technisch noch ungefähr wie heute, aber machst
du ein Buchstaben mehr oder aber machst den Zeichenraum komplexer, dann wird das halt,
ja ja, 2 Millionen Jahre mit Technik von heute wohlgemerkt, ja nicht mit Technik von den 2
Millionen Jahren, dann machst du den Zeichenraum ein bisschen größer, dann sieht man, das
geht halt richtig krasser oben, ja. Und hier sieht man schön den Unterschied von Zeichenlängen,
also von Passwortlängen, guck mal. Es braucht quasi von, nehmen wir mal das, das ist doch
eigentlich ganz schön hier, guck mal. Hier braucht es bei 10 Zeichen, braucht das 3 Tage,
bei 11 Zeichen, bei einem Zeichen mehr, braucht das schon 5 Monate, 24 Jahre, 1000 Jahre,
also ihr seht, das geht einfach richtig stonks rauf mit der Länge des Passwortes, nicht
so sehr, wie man hier sieht, nicht so sehr mit der Komplexität, also mit dem Zeichenvorrat
des Passworts. Deswegen ist es erstmal gar nicht so wichtig, dass euer Passwort möglichst
viele verschiedene Zeichen hat, sondern dass es lang ist. Am besten ist natürlich trotzdem
randomized und möglichst viele Zeichen und sonst was. Naja, sowas, Wörterbuchangriffe,
das wird ja immer gerne in den Raum geworfen. Wörterbuchangriffe kannst du ja nur machen,
wenn du irgendwie eine Ahnung über die Zusammensetzung des Passworts hast, ich meine, du kannst
die immer machen, aber Erfolgsversprechen sind sie eigentlich nur, wenn du irgendwie
Annahmen machen kannst, über die Beschaffenheit des Passworts, weil ansonsten explodiert dir
das damit auch. Naja, Salt und Hashes sind, das ist wieder was ganz anderes, ein Salt
benutzt du dafür, dass du Sachen nicht im Voraus berechnen kannst und Hashes hat mit
Verschlüsselung nichts zu tun oder nicht so direkt. Also ein Hasch ist eigentlich keine
Verschlüsselung, ein Hasch ist eine Einwegfunktion oder sowas in der Richtung, weiß gar nicht,
was da der korrekte Begriff für ist, so aus dem Kopf raus. Also Hasch ist Einweg, Einwegfunktion
war das, genau. Hasch ist One-Way. Verschlüsselung ist offensichtlicherweise 2-Way, weil du kannst
was verschlüsseln und entschlüsseln. Einen Hasch kannst du nicht mehr entschlüsseln.
Hasch ist doch nur Modulu oder nicht? Ne. Modulu ist ein relativ rudimentärer Hasch
ist, ja. Artikel dazu, are your passwords in the green? Ja. Und man muss, wenn man sich
das anguckt, wo habe ich denn jetzt dieses Bild, Leute, das ist zu viel. Ah, hier, hier
ist das Bild. So, natürlich bezieht sich diese Rechnung jetzt Pima einen Daumen und
im Jahr 2022. Also, es ist ja davon auszugehen, dass man in 100.000 Jahren deutlich schnellere
Computer hat und das ist im Endeffekt DES damals auch zum Verhängnis geworden. DES
war nicht geknackt in dem Sinne, dass man quasi das reduzieren konnte, was man an Versuchen
braucht, aber die Schlüssellänge ist so gering, so kurz, dass man es einfach durchprobieren
kann mit heutigen Rechnern. Man kann Hasch nicht entschlüsseln. Was du machen kannst,
ist Kollisionen finden. Also, du kannst zum Beispiel, du kannst, Lollman, danke für
den Zapp, du kannst Hasch nicht entschlüsseln. Du kannst Kollisionen finden. Also, du kannst
einen Inputtext finden, der den gleichen Hasch ergibt. Du kannst niemals sicher sagen, ob
das dieser Inputtext war, den man ursprünglich auch in den Hasch gesteckt hat. Das geht nicht.
Nein, du kannst einen Hasch nicht zurückrechnen, weil ein Hasch quasi nicht alle Informationen
enthält, die in der Ursprungsnachricht drin waren. Das ist ja der Unterschied zur Verschlüsselung.
Wenn du was verschlüsselst, dann ist ja quasi die ganze Information da noch drinne. Du
brauchst noch das richtige Passwort für. Wenn du was durch eine Einweg-Hash-Funktion
jagst, dann kommt am Ende ein mehr oder weniger eindeutiger Schlüssel raus, aber du kannst
keine Rückschlüsse so direkt mehr auf den Ursprungstext ziehen. Du kannst durchprobieren
alle möglichen Texte und du wirst potenziell unendlich viele Inputtexte finden, die den
gleichen Hasch ergeben. Ist ja ganz klar, der Hasch ist kürzer als der Inputtext in
der Regel. Und sobald du sowas hast, muss es quasi unendlich viele Inputs geben, die
immer den gleichen Hasch ergeben. Die Sache ist, dass die Chance sowas zu finden äußerst
gering ist. Und mit äußerst gering meine ich wirklich äußerst gering. Dann sind wir
auch wieder in solchen Regionen hier. Was übrigens auch der Grund ist, warum man MD5
nicht mal verwendet. Bei MD5 gibt es andere Probleme. Ja, was du machen kannst ist, du
kannst Sachen im Voraus berechnen und kannst dir dann ein Mapping speichern von Hasch zu
Inputtext. Davon kannst du ganz viel vorberechnen. Das Problem ist allerdings nur, jetzt überlegt
euch mal, wie viele Kombinationsmöglichkeiten es gibt bei ausreichend langen Hasches. So
ein Hasch ist relativ lang. Okay, das ist die Hexschreibweise, aber ist auch wurscht.
Also es gibt mindestens 5 verschiedene Möglichkeiten dafür. Knapp. Das heißt, du hast ganz schön
lange wo du rechnen musst und du hast verdammt hohen Speicheranforderungen, dass du das speichern
könntest, was dir nicht geht. Du kannst Chart 256 schnell im Voraus berechnen. Und selbst
für den Fall der Fälle, dass du das könntest, dann kommt sowas wie ein Salt ins Spiel. Der
sorgt nämlich dafür, dass du so voraus berechnete Tabellen nicht mehr verwenden kannst, weil
der Salt, der ist zwar public bekannt, aber der sorgt dafür, dass dein im Voraus berechnetes
nicht mehr stimmt, weil du den Salt davor nicht wusstest. MD5 hat noch mehr Probleme,
ist nicht nur zu kurz, das hat auch andere Probleme. Richtig, das ist das beste Beispiel
dafür. Der Chart 256-Hash von einer 2TB-Pornosammlung ist genauso lang wie der Hash von einer 2KB-Text-Natei
oder genauso lang wie der Hash von 1, von dem Text oder auf dem Byte, in dem Fall Bytes
1. Dementsprechend sieht man, dass es potenziell unendlich viele Inputs gibt, die den gleichen
Hashwert ergeben. Das nennt man Kollision an der Stelle. Und die Sache ist bloß die,
die zu finden ist aufwendig und ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es bekannte Chart-256-Kollisionen
gibt. Gibt es welche? Ich weiß es nicht. Gibt es welche? Nein. Okay. Also wir können
davon ausgehen, das ist doch recht aufwendig. Und das ist wieder, das finde ich ist auch
eine interessante Sache. Das wäre fast was, wo man mal so ein Video mit dem Algorithm
und Verstehen Florian drüber machen könnte, weil ich meine, der hat Mathe studiert, der
hat da richtig Massive Brain für. Was ich persönlich recht interessant finde, ist,
es ist unglaublich aufwendig, eine Hash-Kollision zu finden. Also sprich zwei Input-Werte, die
den gleichen Hash ergeben. Nichtsdestotrotz gibt es unendlich viele Input-Werte, die
den gleichen Hash ergeben. Ist verrückt, oder? Es ist so aufwendig oder so unwahrscheinlich,
eine Hash-Kollision zu finden, dass es bis jetzt, bis heute keine bekannte Chart-256-Hash-Kollision
gibt. Wie sieht es bei Bashar-1-Hash-Kollision aus? Okay, da gibt es anscheinend welche,
alles klar. Also es gibt bis heute keine bekannte, aber trotzdem gibt es unendlich viele. Das
ist wir, oder? Das muss erstmal in den Kopf rein. Chat hat das wahrscheinlich schon längst
gelöst, aber Chat möchte nicht so sehr in der Öffentlichkeit stehen, deswegen wird das
nicht veröffentlicht. Der Chat-EQ ist ja heute schon hier über 420. Jetzt haben wir uns mit
Sachen beschäftigt, da wollte ich mich jetzt gar nicht so sehr drüber auslassen, aber
war auch mal wichtig, muss man auch mal ansprechen. Ach ja, übrigens wisst ihr was auch noch ein
witziges Phänomen ist, da weiß ich jetzt aber gerade nicht aus dem Kopf, wie man das
sieht. Da gibt es irgendeinen extra Namen für dieses Phänomen und zwar, wenn man sich
diese Tabelle hier anguckt, wenn man sich diese Tabelle hier anguckt, wie lange dauert
das Passwort dazu zu knacken, was man da sieht ist, dass solche Sachen hier zum Beispiel
mit aktueller Technik 2 Millionen Jahre brauchen. Übrigens, das hier sind wahrscheinlich Ami
Billions, also Milliarden bei uns, aber mit zählen, ehrlich gesagt, irgendwann macht
es das auch nicht mal fett. Zumindest das ist nach aktuellem Stand 2022. Und jetzt ist
die große Frage, da gibt es auch spezielle Modelle für, das ist eigentlich auch richtig
pfeifertig. Jetzt ist die Frage, okay, was ist besser, jetzt anfangen zu rechnen oder,
also mal angenommen, man könnte bloß das eine oder das andere machen. Was ist besser,
jetzt anfangen zu rechnen und in 2 Millionen Jahren das Ergebnis zu haben oder ist es besser,
noch eine Million Jahre zu warten auf verbesserte Technik und dann anfangen zu rechnen?
Also, mit was ist man wahrscheinlich schneller fertig? Weil, wenn man erst in einer Million
Jahre anfängt, hat man eine Million Jahre Rechnung verloren. Warten, weißt du das,
bist du dir da so sicher? 100%, ja, wir gucken dann. Das ist das Gleiche, wie, wann man mit
einem Raumschiff losfliegen sollte zu anderen Sternen. Da gibt es ja auch diese Überlegungen,
so nach dem Motto, ja, wir brauchen jetzt keine Ahnung, was weiß ich, ich habe ehrlich gesagt
keine Ahnung, wie lange wir mit aktueller Technik brauchen würden, aber ich sage jetzt
einfach mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 450.000 Jahre oder so, ich habe keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich
sogar noch zu kurz. Also, sagen wir einfach mal 10.000 Jahre, okay, sagen wir einfach mal,
es ist viel zu kurz, aber sagen wir einfach mal 10.000 Jahre. Lohnt es sich jetzt heute
loszufliegen oder ist es besser zu warten, weil, wenn man wartet und die Technik besser
wird, dann überholt man die anderen irgendwann, wenn man beides macht, denn das geht ja nicht.
Also, in der Überlegung kannst du entweder oder machen oder wartet man noch länger. Und
wann ist der beste Zeitpunkt erreicht? Und das ist ja eigentlich der Knackpunkt. Wann
ist der optimale Zeitpunkt gekommen, nicht mehr zu warten? Das ist auch, wie gesagt,
das ist spannende Fragen, ja. Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, das macht gar keinen so großen
Unterschied, ob man die Angaben hat oder nicht, weil, selbst wenn man jetzt von einem aktuellen
High-End-Rechner ausgeht, mit vier Grafikkarten oder, also, in den Bereichen hier macht das
natürlich was aus, ja, aber spätestens hier ab den gelben Bereichen nicht wirklich, dann
ist wahrscheinlich auch ziemlich wurscht. Das ist wie bei Temperaturen, wenn Temperaturen
irgendwann mal hoch genug sind, ist auch egal, ob Fahrenheit, Celsius oder Kelvin.
Heute ist echt InformatikortTV. Ich sag doch, war zwar gar nicht so geplant im Titel, aber...
Okay, jetzt hat er es. Tim, danke für den Sub. Leute, falls ihr irgendwelche akuten Fragen
habt zu dem ganzen Zeug, was ich mir in den letzten 20 Minuten ausgelassen hab, könnt
ihr jetzt in den Chat stellen, ansonsten machen wir weiter. Ja, das, wie gesagt, das ist natürlich
bei der Überlegung was anderes. Beim Raumschiff ist es ein bisschen einfacher, weil beim Raumschiff
überholst du ja dann auf einmal die Leute, die du losgeschickt hast, vielleicht vor 5.000
Jahren. Welches Betriebssystem bietet für das Programmieren welche Vor-Nachteile? Puh,
das kommt ganz entscheidend drauf an. Was denkst du von Ubiquice? Find ich das eine gute Sache.
Also das mit dem Betriebssystem, das kommt ganz entscheidend drauf an, was du machen
willst. Wenn du Windows Desktop Anwendungen programmieren willst, ist logischerweise Windows
halt sinnvoll. Möchtest du Web-Anwendungen programmieren, ist das Betriebssystem eigentlich
wurscht, aber du müsstest dich schon mal äußern, was du machen willst. Also gehen wir mal von
Web-Anwendungen aus Frontend. Dann ist es eigentlich nahezu egal wo du bist. Es gibt
Browser unter Windows, Linux, Mac. Es gibt Visual Studio Code oder Webstorm oder was
nicht, unter Windows, Linux, Mac. Linux hat für mich den Vorteil, dass es mir nicht auf
den Sack geht im Vergleich zu Windows beim täglichen Benutzen. Und es halt schön viele
Tools hat, die man so braucht, von Wireshark bis Netcat, Telnet, Wegetcurl, alle möglichen
Digga. Ja, deswegen programmiere ich ganz gerne unter Linux und mittlerweile ehrlich
gesagt so die letzten Jahre quasi exklusiv unter Linux. Also ganz selten, ganz selten
noch was unter Windows. Aber ich kenne viele, die mögen das gar nicht so sehr, die stehen
auf Macs, weil Mac schon eine gute Kombination ist aus den ganzen Entwicklertools plus halt
ein bisschen schönere Oberfläche. Es gibt ja Leute, die stehen da drauf. Ich mag meinen
i3. Filing Window Manager beste. Aber wer das halt ein bisschen hübscher haben will,
bleibt halt in Mac. Beste Idee für den Netrider. Keine Frage. Ja, natürlich. Wenn der Webseitenbetreiber
dein Passwort im Klartext speichert und liegt, dann bringt dir noch so lange sicheres Passwort
nichts. Das ist ja logisch. Ist regelmäßiges Passwortwechsel wichtig? Also, wenn man jetzt
von sowas hier ausgeht, dass man Milliarden von Jahren braucht, ein Passwort zu knacken,
aus dem Gesichtspunkt könnte man sagen, nee, ist es nicht. Aber die Welt ist natürlich
nicht perfekt, ist aber logisch an der Stelle, sondern das spielen ja auch menschliche Faktoren
eine Rolle, was dann im Endeffekt heißt, dass vielleicht der Webseitenbetreiber trotzdem
mal dein Passwort liegt. Und wenn das passiert, ist es natürlich sinnvoll. Meistens sind
diese Leaks ja zeitverzögert, wenn das Passwort, was da drinnen steht, einfach nicht mehr
gültig ist. Und am besten ist, wenn du keine Passworte hast, die gleichen bei mehreren
Diensten, weil ansonsten liegt Pornhub dein Passwort aus Versehen und man hat gleichzeitig
Zugang zu deinem E-Mail-Postfach. Das will man nicht unbedingt haben. Bei der Stelle
ist natürlich Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung auch. Oder wie Julien Bam, drei Faktor oder
ja komm, warum nicht gleich Fünf-Faktor-Authentifizierung? Unter Fünf-Faktor-Authentifizierung mach ich
meinen Rechner nicht mehr an. Also ja, es ist schon sinnvoll, seine Passworte ab und
zu mal zu ändern. Aber viel wichtiger finde ich, dass du unterschiedliche Passworte für
unterschiedliche Dienste hast. Wann nächstes Programmier-Stream? Gute Frage. Wird mal wieder
Zeit. Der Label-Champ muss noch fertig gebaut werden. Wusstest du, dass Twitch Prime die
kostenlose Möglichkeit hat, ein Streamer deiner Wahl einmal im Monat kostenlos... Wie ist
das immer noch so? Ich dachte, Prime-Subs sind kaputt. Oder? Nee, Prime-Subs gehen
glaube ich noch, aber die Benachrichtigung ist kaputt bei Prime-Subs. Ich glaube, der
Sound geht nicht mehr, wenn man Prime-Subbt. Das wars glaube ich. Vielleicht haben sie
das auch wieder gefixt. Müsste man mal testen. Ah! Keylogs, danke schön für den Sub. Der
Naron Bescher. Oh, ein LoL-Spieler. Am Start. Danke für den Sub. Jawoll, hat funktioniert.
Pog. So muss das sein. Bis man darauf wartet, dass Safari was unterstützt, dann ist mein
E. Also ganz ehrlich, bis Safari mal Web-Notification und PWAs ordentlich unterstützt, da bin ich
mir nicht sicher, was eher eintritt. Dieses Pass-Mode-Chart oder das Safari, das man macht.
Lambo 8888, danke für den Sub. Jetzt flutscht es. Was ist mit Chromebooks? Weiß ich nicht.
Ich hab noch nie ein Chromebook verwendet. Hast du schon mal MacOS benutzt? Nie wirklich
lange. Ich hatte mal ein, weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das hieß. Irgendwie so ein Custom-Bootloader
auf einer alten Kiste drauf, wo man Mac booten konnte. Das hatte ich immer ein paar Monate
stehen und hab es ab und zu verwendet. MacOS hat coole Programme. Man kann sich jetzt, Clover
kann sein, ja. Man kann sich jetzt über die Praktiken von Apple und was die da treiben
und so kann man sich alles streiten. Aber MacOS hat schon coole Programme. Zum Beispiel,
das fand ich damals cool als Visio-Ersatz. Mittlerweile mach ich das einfach bei anderen
Seiten. Das fand ich damals sehr nice als Visio-Ersatz. Oder auch für Organisations-Sachen
und Notizen oder irgendwelche. Es gab schon ein paar coole Dinge unter MacOS, aber ansonsten
hab ich für mich jetzt nicht so den Vorteil erkannt. Was cool war unter MacOS, du kannst
halt die meisten Programme, die man so, die meisten Open Source, guckst du das CSGO Major?
Aktuell nicht, aber ich gucke gerne CSGO. Wenn das jetzt nicht gerade parallel läuft
dann schon. Aber wahrscheinlich nicht von Anfang bis Ende. Wahrscheinlich guck ich
Finals und irgendwie eins davor oder so. Aber ich wusste dann nicht so genau, wofür ich
es verwenden soll. Zumal es mittlerweile auch immer schwieriger wird sowas zu betreiben,
weil spätestens mit ihrem eigenen CPU wird das natürlich schwierig auf x86 Hardware
noch Mac laufen zu lassen in Zukunft. Und es war halt cool, dass du die ganzen von Linux
bekannten oder die meisten Open Source-Dinger installieren konntest. Mit Homebrew unter
MacOS. Aber großartige Mac-Erfahrungen hab ich tatsächlich nicht. Sehe ich auch aktuell
nicht ein, wozu ich das bräuchte, weil ich bin mit meinem Linux als Entwicklungsumgebung
eigentlich rundum zufrieden. Gibt ein paar Dinge ab und zu mal, die mich nerven, wenn
man wieder irgendwelche Default-Config ändert, sodass dann mein Programm, was ich benutze,
um Sachen zu launchen, auf einmal einen weißen Hintergrund wieder hat. Aber im Großen und
Ganzen sind das Kleinigkeiten. Das ist richtig. Passwort, die gleichen Passwörter, aber mehreren
Dienste zu haben ist blöd. Du bist in der neuen VPN, ach so ist das gut. Ich hoffe
auch noch ein paar SSH-Tunnel. Und über Tor. 9 Euro Ticket nach Sylt. Ist das wirklich
eingetreten, was die Leute da Panik hatten, dass jetzt alle nach Sylt... Ah nee, Moment,
das ist ja das Ticket, gibt's ja noch nicht. Ich glaube, das wird nicht so heiß gegessen
wie es gekocht wird jetzt gerade. Und Sylt wird nicht überrannt sein durch irgendwelche
Touristen mit 9 Euro Ticket. Aber ganz davon abgesehen, selbst wenn, die geben trotzdem
da Geld aus. Ich glaube, das ist wieder sowas, wo sie... Ich bin mal gespannt, ja.
Was? Saurei, danke für deinen Sub. Anzeige ist raus.
Ja, ja. Das ist auch eines der Probleme, die du bei übermäßig komplexen Passwortrichtlinien
hast. Die Leute suchen sich dann irgendwas, was vielleicht durch die Passwortrichtlinien
durchgeht, aber eigentlich viel zu simpel ist. Oder aber sie hängen nur noch Einser
hinten dran. Oder aber sie hängen sich einen Zettel an den Bildschirm. Ja, das muss man
sich alles überlegen. Letztendlich ist beim Thema Sicherheit eigentlich immer die große
Preisfrage, wie praktikabel ist es, weil im Endeffekt ist Sicherheit immer eine Abwägung
aus sicher versus bequem. Und du kannst nicht auf jegliche Bequemlichkeit verzichten, weil
das macht keiner lange mit. Und im Endeffekt ist es danach vielleicht sogar unsicherer,
weil die Leute keinen Bock mehr haben. Das ist genauso, wie wenn ich jetzt sagen würde,
ich verwende nur noch einen Browser, der beim Schließen alle Cookies und alle Sessions
und alle Sachen im Cache löscht. Das wäre von der Idee her natürlich super, weil wenn
mir dann mal sowas passiert, wie Julien Bam, dass irgendjemand einen Trojaner auf meinem
Rechner hat und meinen Browser fernsteuern kann, dann wäre das erstmal nicht mehr ganz
so schlimm. Es sei denn, er erwischt mich gerade, wie ich den Browser zufällig offen
habe und noch YouTube-Aufhabe eingeloggt. Aber das ist so unpraktikabel und abfuck zu
bedienen, das macht keiner. Du machst das gleiche Passwort überall. Na gut, wir wissen
ja alle, also das beste Passwort der Welt ist 123456. Das ist erprobt, das ist das
meistverbreitetste Passwort der Welt, das ist sozusagen best practice. Das kann eigentlich
nur gut sein. Tja. Was ist deine Meinung zu Password-Mate? Das finde ich gut, wobei
Bitwarden selbst würde ich nicht verwenden, ich würde nie Cloud-Anbieter verwenden für
meine Passwörter. Aber die lokalen Installationen davon oder ganz klassisch KeyPass ist eine
super Geschichte. Natürlich, es birgt auch Risiken, muss man an der Stelle auch nochmal
erzählen. Passwort-Manager ist nicht gleich alles Friede, Freude. Wenn man zum Beispiel
KeyPass hat und irgendjemand hat wirklich, wie würde das Semper-Video jetzt sagen, Schadwehr
auf deinen Rechner drauf bekommen und du öffnest KeyPass und die greifen aus deinem
Rahmen Passwörter ab, das geht natürlich auch. Also es ist wie so vieles nicht ganz
ohne immer, aber allemal besser als Passwort-TXT auf dem Desktop. Wie du KeyPass singst,
mehrere Möglichkeiten. Entweder nimmst du sowas wie Dropbox oder Google Drive, wenn
man das öffentlich hinlegen will. Ich persönlich finde es besser, sowas wie Nass zu machen
oder über Sync-Things oder Nextcloud oder Z-File oder was auch immer, was da alles so
gibt. Muss man nur gucken, dass man sich zeitgleich an zwei unterschiedlichen Orten bearbeitet,
dann gibt es Sync-Konflikte. Ansonsten, wenn man die Sachen nur daheim braucht, ist sowas
wie Web-Basiertes wie beispielsweise Bitwarden ganz gut, wobei Vaultkeeper heißt das jetzt
glaube ich. Wie heißt das jetzt, das zum selbst installieren. Vaultwarden, nicht Vaultkeeper,
Vaultwarden. Die wollten wahrscheinlich nicht, dass es sich Bitwarden nennt, weil es so sehr
mit dem Produkt was zu tun hat, kein Schimmer. Zumindest, das ist auch ganz gut. Letztendlich
hast du da einfach die Probleme an anderen Stellen. Es ist aber allemal besser als Passport
TXT. Und wenn ihr gar nichts davon machen wollt, das einfachste was ihr machen könnt,
zumindest wenn ihr Firefox verwendet, ich weiß nicht ob Chrome das mittlerweile kann.
Wenn ihr Firefox verwendet, ist folgendes, ihr geht in die Settings und sagt Master Passport
festlegen. Use Primary Passport. Dann müsst ihr einmal beim Start von Firefox, oder nee
ich glaube, wenn das erste Mal ein Passwort Autocompleted wird, müsst ihr ein Master Passport
eingeben, das Firefox an die Passwörter entschlüsselt. Wenn ihr sonst nichts machen wollt und Firefox
verwendet, ist das die einfachste Variante, eine ganze Ecke sicherer die Passwörter zu
speichern, die man im Browser schon hinterlegt hat. Analog aufschreiben ist auch okay. Passwörter
in den Schrank legen, Passwörter auf den Schreibtisch legen und so. Alles kein großes
Ding, weil auf eurem Rechner irgendwelche Viren drauf bekommen, ist einfacher für
irgendeinen Hacker-Man, als bei euch auf dem Schreibtisch zu gucken. Da müsst ihr nämlich
einfach euch einbrechen und das werden die meisten nicht machen. Ich hatte früher, wo
ich das Passwort sehe, ich hatte früher mal für meinen E-Mail-Postfach hatte ich Katze
1, 2, 3, oder ich glaube sogar Katze 1, 2, 3, Katze 1, 2, 3, oder ich weiß nicht ob
1-fach oder 2-fach und auf einmal hieß es, ich darf keine E-Mails mehr versenden, weil
ich Spam verschickt habe und ich muss jetzt ganz dringend beweisen, dass es mein Konto
ist und so. Katze 1, 2, 3 war halt nicht das beste Passwort. Leaked! Oh nein, mein Passwort
ist rausgekommen. Mein Passwort, was ich mal hatte, als ich 15 war oder so. Katze 1, 2,
3. Das ist tatsächlich schwierig aufzuschreiben, aber so Passwörter würde ich auch ehrlich
gesagt nicht verwenden. Nur normal, ASCII und fertig. Da hätte ich viel zu viele Gedanken,
dass irgendwelche Webseiten das verkacken. So habe ich das noch gar nicht gesehen, aber
ein Zettel auf dem Schreibtisch ist zwei Faktor in gewisser Weise. Das Passwort ist das eine
Faktor und die Haustür ist der zweite Faktor, da ist schon was dran. Passwort ist Passwort,
das heißt du benutzt als dein Passwort Passwort. Ja, da kommt nie jemand drauf. Das hat noch
nie jemand vor dir erst noch auf diese clevere Idee gekommen. Ich glaube du bist der erste
dem das hier eingefallen ist. Ja, da gibt es eine Antwort zu. Ja Leute, heute war tatsächlich
InformatikorTV angesagt. Da habe ich mir über Themen ausgelassen, da hatte ich gar nicht
vor drüber zu sprechen, aber muss auch mal sein. Irgendwelche YouTube Sachen gucken können
wir jetzt nicht, weil gleich ist Bedgetime. Nichts eingekauft, Amazon ist jetzt pleite.
Doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, ich habe was eingekauft, guck mal. Ich habe das da
schon bestellt und das da schon bestellt. Ich habe, ich habe nur, ich habe nur den Wasserkocher
noch nicht bestellt. Übrigens, wo wir gerade haben, oh, oh, es ist billiger geworden.
Zwei Cent. Übrigens Leute, ich habe mal, ich habe mal eine Frage an euch, das können
wir uns die letzten paar Minuten noch angucken. Welchen SCUF Controller soll ich mir holen?
Oder welcher SCUF Controller ist POG? Xbox Controller. Instinct. Welcher SCUF Controller
taugt? Was, was, die Dinger sehen schon cool aus. 214 Euro, Alter. Okay, der Grund warum
ich gucke ist folgendes. Ich habe letztens, will ich das so genau erzählen? Ich weiß
nicht ob, ja doch, das glaube ich kein Ding. Ich kenne auch jemand von früher, der jetzt
bei SCUF arbeitet in Deutschland und da hat gemeint, wir können doch da mal irgendwas
machen. Ich habe gesagt, ehrlich gesagt, ich brauche überhaupt keinen Controller, aber
ich gucke mal, ob es irgendwas gibt, was mich so direkt anspricht. Und die Preise haben es
schon in sich, oder? Was ist ein SCUF? Ja, die, hier, diese Custom Controller. Die Preise
haben es schon in sich. Ich meine, 214 Euro. Für mich kommen nur Xbox Controller infrage.
Ich mag den Playstation Controller nicht. Was ist an denen so besonders? Die sehen cool
aus. Die haben Pedals auf der, auf dem Boden. Nein, nein, ja, im Prinzip nur für das Case.
Also guck, die haben, ich weiß gar nicht, sieht man das von unten hier irgendwo? Die
haben, die haben so, die haben so Pedale unten am, also nicht für den Fuß, sondern so zum,
ne, der hier gar nicht. Doch, hier, doch, guck. Der hat hier so Dinger unten noch mal zum drücken,
das ist für die ganzen Jumpshotter. Kannste, kannst du den Call of Duty besser um die Ecke
Jumpshotten? Wobei die richtig coolen Sachen, die SCUF Controller, die haben doch diese
Pedale unten, nicht diese Knöpfe. Ach, was auch immer. Ich brauche ehrlich gesagt überhaupt
kein, aber ich dachte mir halt so, wenn man schon mal die Chance hat und man da nicht so
viel für machen muss, dann, warum kein SCUF Controller? Pro-Gamer rein durch Controller,
easy. Das ist ja hier, Qt, Qt Controller. Xbox Controller, hier, das, das, das meine
ich hier. Diese, diese Pedale, die sind voll angesagt. Und die gibt es aber nur bei PS5
oder wie. Die Pedale. Apple verliert hochrangigen KI Manager wegen Rückkehrpflicht ins Büro.
Moment, das muss ich kurz lesen. Der Elite von MS hat die auch, okay. Ich will ja, ich
brauche ja gar keinen Controller, wenn schon, wenn ich den SCUF Controller, weil sich das
gerade so ergeben hat. So, von wann ist der Artikel? Heute, wahrscheinlich. Apple hat
erstmals einen bekannten Manager verloren, weil der Konzern so strikt rum. Ja, richtig
so. Haut alle ab. Ja, bei uns lassen sie das Thema jetzt ein bisschen ruhen, weil sie
irgendwie mitbekommen haben, die Leute rennen ihnen weg. Direktor des Bereichs maschinelles
Lernen. Was? Ion, wie spricht man das aus? Leon, ist es nie oder ein L? Ion, Ion, Goodfellow
will nicht mehr in Cupertino arbeiten. Tja, hat er recht. Wenn die keinen Bock auf es
haben, dann, und tschüss. Geh, dann soll er zur Microsoft gehen. Oder sonst wo, um
die Ecke. Nein, Cupertino ist glaube ich nicht so viel, um die Ecke. Ähm, soll er sonst
wo hingehen? Die anderen sind da nicht ganz so heftig drauf wie Apple. Ich meine, gut,
Apple hat sich so ein fettes Glas Ding hingestellt, wo die Leute manchmal gegen die Türen laufen.
Wer es mir nicht glaubt, googelt mal, äh, googelt, äh, googelt mal Apple Hauptquartier
Verletzungen. Die Leute verletzen sich regelmäßig an Türen, die zu blank poliert sind und laufen
gegen Glaswände im Apple Hauptquartier. Kein Witz, guckt nach, wenn ihr es mir nicht glaubt.
Ähm, die müssen schon öfters, die mussten da schon öfters mal den Krankenwagen rufen,
weil die Leute blutige Nasen hatten von der, von der Fuff. Kein Spaß, Leute, guckt nach.
Weil die Leute Verletzungen hatten, weil sie gegen die Türen gelaufen sind. Ist eigentlich
so hängen geblieben. Apple Hauptsitz Verletzung Türen. Deshalb schlagen sich Apple Mitarbeiter
die Körpfe blutig. Glas Türen im Apple Park. Immer mehr Unfälle. Ist schon ein bisschen
her, gib mich zu, ist schon ein bisschen her. Das hat sich bei mir mal eingebrannt. Oh Gott,
fuck. Das war, das passt aber zu typisches Apple Design. Es muss erst mal geil aussehen.
Danach ist es erst mal nicht so richtig, ja. So, zumindest der Typ ist anscheinend abgehauen,
weil die ihm zu restriktiv sind mit Homeoffice. Kann ich bloß sagen, richtig gemacht. Umstrittener
Return to Work Politik. Mindestens einen Tag pro Woche zurück. Das mache ich ja auch aktuell.
Seit Anfang Mai sind es zwei Tage. Besonders, ach so, hybrides Arbeiten. Ja, die werden
ja nicht müde, irgendeinen Bullshit schön zu umschreiben. Es ist übrigens tatsächlich,
da hängt mehr dran, als man denkt. Ein Kollege von mir auf der Arbeit, der ist umgezogen.
Er wohnte in der Nähe von Frankfurt. Und als das Unternehmen, wo ich jetzt arbeite,
also die Bank in Frankfurt, wo ich arbeite, die hat gesagt, Jungs, Homeoffice, wir sind
voll modern, wir unterstützen das. Und daraufhin hat der gesagt, ich ziehe jetzt um, ein bisschen
weiter weg, ein bisschen in ländliche Regionen, wo es billiger ist zu leben, wo die Miete
nicht so teuer ist. Seine Freundin studiert jetzt irgendwie auch wieder, das heißt, sie
haben eh nicht so viel Geld. Und für den war das super, der ist umgezogen. Und jetzt
ein Jahr später haben die bei uns angefangen, so nach dem Motto, ah, mit Homeoffice ist
vielleicht doch nicht so geil. Und der hat auch gesagt, wenn ich auf die Arbeit wieder
kommen soll, mehr als einen Tag die Woche, dann kündige ich instant. Was ich aus seiner
Sicht auch komplett verstehe. So extrem sehe ich es persönlich jetzt nicht. Aber ich bin
auch ganz stark am Überlegen, mir dann was anderes zu suchen. Aber ich kann es verstehen.
Du kannst ja nicht auf der einen Seite den Leuten sagen, ja, easy, kein Problem. Dann
treffen die so folgenschwere Entscheidungen wie umziehen woanders hin und dann sagen sie,
ach, nee, doch nicht. Selbstschuld. Was sie machen bezüglich der Geldprobleme,
zum Beispiel aus Frankfurt wegzuziehen. Apple schreibt seinen Managern sogar die Tage vor,
an denen ihre Teammitglieder vor Ort sein müssen. Sollten das nicht die Manager eigentlich
managen? Sind Manager nicht dafür da, sowas zu managen? Aber was auch immer. Nur Freitag
und Mittwoch dürfen normalerweise Tage Remote Days. Microsoft ist da komplett anders drauf.
Microsoft ist ja remote weiterhin hoch im Kurs. Scheint das einzige Foto zu sein, was es von
ihm gibt, oder? Sollte ich High-Res Bild, ist das jetzt auch nicht. Ja. Tja. Magie,
das ist ein typisches Bullshit-Wort, was man bei uns auch, das kann ich mir richtig gut
vorstellen, dass das einer bei uns demnächst auch ausgräbt. Ja, finde ich gut so. So und
hier jetzt der Ort der Niedertracht, das Heiseforum. Ja. Der wird easy was anderes finden, der
Typ. Ja, garantiert. Das ist auch so. Das ist auch so. Bei uns sind schon einige Leute
abgehauen durch das pure Androhen dieser Sache. Es gehen jetzt demnächst noch mehr und es
alleine hat schon gereicht dafür, dass das Management jetzt gesagt hat, man sollte das
vielleicht eher weniger thematisieren. Also man sieht, dass das was bringt. Und gerade
im IT-Sektor, wenn man nicht gerade Facebook, Google, Apple, Microsoft, Netflix ist und
die Leute quasi von der ganzen Welt zu einem wollen, hat man seine Schwierigkeiten Leute
zu bekommen. Und wenn man dann noch sich quasi zusätzlich absichtlich unattraktiv
macht für Arbeitgeber, ja, dann ist ja nur wirklich kein Wunder, dass man niemand bekommt.
Ja, warte mal ab, bis du unterschrieben hast. Die erzählen einem am Anfang viel.
Wieso sind Heise-Kommentare eigentlich immer so heftig toxic? Keine Ahnung. Also viele Spasten
am Start sind auf Heise. Semper-Video-Rate, ist der on? Ist der Sprecher da? Ist der Sprecher
online? Nö, ist er gar nicht, oder? Doch, ist er. Ist er gerade online gekommen. Lul.
Komm wir raiden Semper-Video. Wir raiden den Sprecher. Was, was, was macht er denn überhaupt?
Macht er denn heute überhaupt? Computer-Talk, alles klar, gut. Der Wubbler ist raided jetzt.
Zockst du mal Arma mit Semper-Video? Ich zocke auch nicht mal Arma ohne Semper-Video,
außerdem, außerdem, wir kennen uns gar nicht. Okay Leute, also wir sehen uns im nächsten
Stream. Bis dann, machts gut, see you.